at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they're worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom
of my feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n try theragon risk-free
for
30 days there's no substitute for the
gen 4 theragon with an oled screen
that's oled for those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app
an incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragun.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine
use them on their it bands after long
runs there are a million ways to use it
and the gen fourth era guns
start at just 199 dollars i said i have
two
i have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves these soft
attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by thrive
market thrive market saves me a ton of
money and it's perfect for these crazy
times
thrive market is a membership-based site
on a mission to make healthy living easy
and affordable
for everyone you can regularly save 25
to 50 percent
off of normal retail prices with
member-only prices for
anything you can imagine really whether
it's keto paleo gluten-free vegan
whatever you can sort by that
you can find all types of food you can
find supplements you can find non-toxic
home products
clean wine dog food just about anything
and let me give you a personal example
of just how much
you can save so my last order i ordered
primal kitchen
mayonnaise which is made with avocado
oil it's delicious justin's almond
butter
and the first was 25 off the
justin's almond butter was 30 off rouse
homemade marinara sauce which is awesome
26
off all said and done at the end of my
shopping i saved 39 on
my order so members and i'm a member can
earn wholesale prices every day and save
an average of 30
on each order i'll come back to that and
through thrive
gives their one-on-one membership
matching program every paid
thrive market membership is matched with
a free one for a low-income family in
need
and you can try thrive market a few
different ways they have
the monthly membership which is 9.95 per
month they have the 12-month membership
for five dollars a month which is built
at 59.95
and right now this is exclusive to you
guys you can get up to a
20 shopping credit when you join today
now remember that i saved 39
on my order so basically with one or two
orders i pay for
the annual membership which is pretty
sweet so go to thrivemarket.com
forward slash tim to give thrive market
a try you can like i said
choose between the membership models
you'd like to test out
if it doesn't work for you you can
cancel for any reason within 30 days
for a full refund and on top of that
you will make back your membership and
savings as i have or
they give you credits to make up for the
difference so it's really
win-win-win all around and i would
suggest you check it out
go to thrivemarket.com forward slash tim
you can receive up to twenty dollars in
shopping credit that's com forward slash
thrivemarket.com
for up to 20 in shopping credit plus all
of the other
great stuff that i mentioned one more
time check it out thrive market dot com
forward slash tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
and i am thrilled to have a friend as a
guest today bradfeld
on twitter at befeld feld brad is the
author of two new books
the startup community way and the second
edition of startup communities he has
been an early stage investor and
entrepreneur since 1987.
i've been reading his writing forever it
seems prior to co-founding foundry group
he co-founded mobius venture capital and
prior to that
founded intensity ventures brad is also
a co-founder of techstars
he's written a number of books as part
of the startup revolution series and
writes the blogs
failed thoughts and adventure deals two
of my favorite
blogs out there which really are i think
timeless and a lot of the lessons that
are taught brad holds
bachelor of science and master of
science degrees in management science
from the massachusetts institute of
technology aka
mit brad is also an art collector and
long distance
runner he has completed 25 marathons as
part of his mission to finish a marathon
in each of the 50 states brad welcome to
the show it's nice to have you
tim thanks for having me it's awesome to
be here
i can't wait to dig in you and i have
had a number of conversations
and i've never failed to take notes
and learn and this is no exception this
is just a selfish indulgence on my part
yet again
on this podcast i thought we'd begin
with
your first off-grid vacation and the
genesis of how that came to be
if you wouldn't mind rewinding the clock
and
coloring that in for us yeah let's let's
start with something really calm
and relaxed and easy
uh so i'm married to a woman named amy
batchelor
and we've been together now for almost
30 years
the first uh off-grid vacation i took
was a result of a moment in time
uh where amy said to me uh i'm done
and i thought she meant that she was
done with the week because it had been a
really shitty week for me
but she was actually saying very quietly
you know i've had enough
of living this way with you
this is mid 2000 so we're in the
middle of the deflation of the internet
bubble it has not
crashed yet it crashed in 2001 but it's
definitely deflating
fast and in uh sort of the
the arc for me as an investor from about
1996 to 2000 was
unbelievably intense on the rise up like
you know if you sneezed you made money
uh the stupidest
ideas were successful and then that all
continued until one day that was no
longer true
and so middle of 2000 i'm traveling all
over the country because i invest all
over the country
i'm doing my best to sort of keep
everything together
i'm trying to save what is a portfolio
that i have that's falling apart
very very quickly several companies that
i co-founded
along with a lot of companies that i was
on the board of or an investor in
and amy and i were literally just seeing
ourselves on the weekends so my week
would start on monday morning
i'd get up early at usually four o'clock
colorado time
i'd go to dia i'd take the 6 a.m united
flight to the bay area
i'd spend monday all day in a partner
meeting
at the firm i was at then which was
during that period of time called
softbank venture capital or stopping
technology ventures
ultimately became called mobius venture
capital
and you know i'd stay the night tuesday
i'd spend
all day in the bay area and then i was a
co-chairman of a public company
on the east coast in new york and
purchased so i take a red eye usually on
tuesday night or wednesday night spend a
couple of days in new york
maybe on friday go somewhere else and
eventually come back home
uh crash for the weekend just out of
exhaustion
uh catch up on whatever i could catch up
on and then
sort of amy would patch me up and send
me back out monday morning and i'd do it
again
week after week for a lot of weeks
um this particular uh friday that this
started
she and i had planned a vacation to
friend's house
a longtime friend of mine a guy named
warren katz and his wife alana
katz who had been my seventh employee in
my first company
and warren and i had been making
been bus you know entrepreneurial
friends forever
from when i lived in boston and just
good personal friends
and they had a house in newport in
addition to boston and so
i met amy in boston black car must have
picked her up at the airport
came and picked me up at whatever
company i had been spending the morning
at
we took the car out to uh newport
uh and i was on the phone the entire
time and i'm on the phone like having
these conversations that with the
benefit of hindsight were ultimately
futile you know
every conversation that i had during
that period of time none of them
had any positive impact a meaningful way
on the outcomes of these companies
and you know i probably in between calls
i looked over at her and said hey
sweetie nice to see you looking forward
to the weekend
we get to our friend's house probably
around three our friends are ready for a
beautiful
summer evening in newport and
i'm still working right i'm on telephone
calls i'm dealing with
you know my email i'm doing whatever
and eventually it's six o'clock and we
go to dinner
and we go to dinner at some restaurant
and i you know by this point i'm
sort of trying to be in the moment a
little bit without really realizing
what's going on
and about i don't know we order
10 15 minutes into dinner just as as
salads are being served i get another
phone call and i just pick up the phone
and i walk out i'm i'm smart enough to
get away
out of the table and go outside and i
talk on the phone for a while
and i come back and they're having
dessert and you know you kind of know
when you're in a relationship and you're
[ __ ] up right
signals are not that hard to read um but
you know we went back to our friend's
house and you know by then we sort of
you know had another
you know whatever a little more time
together and then eventually go to bed
and we're crawling into bed
and amy says very quietly to me she says
i'm done
and i responded yeah this was a brutal
week i'm tired god everything's so hard
right now all these companies blah blah
whatever
so glad this week is over i'm looking
forward to having a weekend with you she
says no
that's not what i meant she she says
you're not even a good roommate anymore
she says i love you i think you're
awesome but i don't want to live this
way and i don't want to watch you do
this to yourself
and i i had enough wisdom this is in my
uh about 35. i have enough wisdom to
know not to go to bed or not to roll
over when you're
like when your wife says that to you
so you know we talked for about an hour
and i kind of
i'd like to say i talked her off the
ledge of being done i
i said to her you know what this weekend
no phone
no computer i'm done i gave her my phone
i gave her my computer i said put them
in your bag
between now and when we leave here
monday morning i'm not going to do any
work i'm not going to think about work
and i just want to spend time talking
about what we need to do differently
what i need to do differently
and uh you know after about an hour like
all right
things are calmed down and you know
we're we're kind of starting to
doze a little and you know i i knew
better than to sort of nudge her and say
you know so any action happening tonight
um because you know like
that all that was going to generate was
was more laughter so we we go to bed
uh we we wake up the next morning and
we go for a walk and i said look
i know that you're not happy with the
dynamics here
but i don't want to split up i love you
you're the person i was put on this
planet for
i think i was the person you're put on
this planet for
i've got an engineer's brain i just give
me some rules
and she looks at me and her first
response is i don't want to give you
rules like that puts it on me
and that's not romantic and then she
sort of snaps into focus and she says
you mean i get to control you
and i said i said yeah yeah just give me
some rules
and all right so we walk a little bit
more and she says all right
if the first thing i want you to do is i
want you to keep
track each day of how many hours you
work and i want you to report them to me
now she knew that this was pressing a
gigantic
red button in the middle of my forehead
and it's what our significant others do
right it's
and what we do to them like you know the
biggest
point of pain or the biggest you know
trigger
of your significant other if you have
one and and they know of yours and
she was doing and that and she was doing
it on purpose my first company we kept
track of time in five minute increments
the software consulting business
and every day and we and this was 1980s
so we kept track on a piece of paper
so for seven years i ran this company
for seven years
every day including weekends i had like
a paper
grid that i filled out 9 10 to 9
25 and then a code for you know which
client i worked on and then a one
sentence description what i did just
like lawyers do
but we did day in day out and when we
sold that company i said i am never
[ __ ] doing that again i'm never doing
something where i have to keep track of
my time again
and so my first reaction was no i'm not
going to do that and she looked at me
she says
you said i could make the rules so
we ended up having an amazing set of
conversations that weekend didn't solve
anything but there were two things that
came out of it
one was a bunch of tactics and i'll talk
about one in particular in a sec
but the other was real clarity
for what was wrong and it wasn't hard
for her to
say it and articulate it and it wasn't
hard for me to hear it
but it had to be said and it had to be
articulated and the specific thing
that was wrong was my words didn't match
my actions
and that has become a foundational part
of my relationship with amy
and a key part of how i try to live
although we we're human we make you know
i make mistakes i screw up plenty
but i try to have my words match my
actions and in the
context of the relationship i'll use the
phone call as an example this is
before uh you know we had iphones before
there was even
on your cell phone caller id you just
saw a phone number
and you actually i think had to have
like a caller id
special thing on your home phone and so
somebody would call me on my cell phone
and i'd be in the middle of a
conversation with her we'd be at the
middle of dinner we'd be in the middle
of a movie or we'd be in the middle of
name your other
you know thing that two adults do and
my phone would ring and i'd answer it no
matter what was going on between us no
matter what sort of the interaction was
because i prioritized
the random person who was calling me
over amy yet my words were
amy you're the most important person in
my life being with you
is the most treasured thing i have i
like to be with you more than anything
else sorry i gotta answer this phone
call
and you could do it with phone calls you
could do it with emails you could do
with work you could be
you know i was late to every single
thing we ever did because i just had one
more thing to do before i went to the
dinner that we had scheduled for
a fancy night out or whatever so
when she said to me your words don't
match your actions
and then gave me an example that really
snapped into place and that's been
foundational
the other part of it was and this is a
thing i've learned about amy i don't
have much of a temper
um i suppress my anger and frustration
i'm like
i'm marge simpson and i just push it
down to my toes
and i have lots of other ways to process
it some that are not particularly
healthy which i
expect you'll probe me on at some point
um but i don't have much of a temper it
takes a lot to get me to react
with anger external anger amy has a
temper
um and i learned early on in our
relationship that there was no value in
trying to win
when her temper started to escalate it
was you know mutually assured
destruction she'd just keep escalating
i'd escalate she'd escalate i'd escalate
she'd escalate eventually like lay on
the ground like
like your dog that says you know just
pet me on the stomach i give up i yield
and in this particular moment she said
uh the reason i'm so angry
right now is i'm scared i'm scared for
you
i think you're killing yourself i don't
think you're having fun
i don't think you're enjoying what
you're doing i don't think you're
creating enough space for you
and i'm she didn't say i'm enabling that
but that would be the language we'd use
today
and so from that came this idea of
basically a quarterly vacation off the
grid so each quarter since 2000
we take a week saturday to saturday and
we just go off the grid
and i'm fortunate that i can take four
weeks of vacation like that a year
and you know we screw up some sometimes
we don't end up doing it or end up
sort of being on or off it took probably
a dozen times before it wasn't a
terrifying experience
the process literally of turning off my
phone
and leaving my computer at home when we
got on a plane and went somewhere for
for a week of vacation was so incredibly
anxiety producing
the challenge that i had for the first
couple of days of disconnecting from the
momentum of my
work life and shifting into this
open space and time in front of me with
the person i loved the most
was so hard to do but it was so worth it
you know three or four years later the
muscle that was built
was four times a year uh i kind of just
say to the rest of the world [ __ ] it
and disappear for a week and as far as i
can tell
you know all of those fears that i have
oh by the way there's a lot of anxieties
that
one has when they go away right if i'm
not here for this meeting this bad thing
will happen
or this will happen or i won't sell this
stock or i won't
you know be i won't close this
investment or i'll miss this new
opportunity or whatever right i'll
pick your business anxiety well yeah all
those things happened
but none of them were none of them were
significant they weren't meaningful
relative to the meaning and the value of
being able to spend this time
with amy and with me uh the two of us
together
doing what we wanted to do rather than
doing what the rest of the world wanted
to do
i'd love to ask a few follow-ups about
the quarterly off-the-grid vacation
was the let's just call it one-year
withdrawal process i mean was it wasn't
i used that term deliberately was it
just
a psychological heroin heroin-like
withdrawal process
after which you were more relaxed or
were there changes that you made to the
format or the timing or what you did
that helped to reduce the anxiety of
taking the week
off the grid and for people who are
wondering what that means just to
underscore what you said that's no work
no email no calls no web surfing no news
it is off grid yeah it took more than a
year to detox
or to you know to to get into a place
where
it was like flipping a switch today it's
um
there's there i have a ritual right my
ritual is on friday night i turn on my
email responder
my email responder usually says
something like
i'm taking a week off the grid i'm not
checking email when i get back i'm
archiving all my emails so i will not
see this email if you want me to see it
send it to me again
after you know day x which is usually
tuesday
not the following monday because i come
back to monday and 75 people send me
emails first thing monday morning
you know it's like okay now i'm just
dealing with last week and you know not
surprisingly the
whatever pick the number i don't know a
thousand new emails a week or
whatever couple thousand new emails a
week that come in
you know it's it's kind of nice to just
start monday morning with nothing
in your inbox it took me a while to
figure that out so for
you know the first couple of years i i
would put a vacation reminder up but i
come back to this
onslaught and i'd live again the
previous week
so it wasn't as though i got to not
experience that week
in the rest of my world i had to go live
it again on monday morning and by the
end of the day monday
all of the things that happened over the
week were
again in my head versus if i just
deleted the week yeah some of them were
important and they'd surface again
but the vast majority of them were not
important just cognitive dissonance over
you know overhead i didn't need
second was cheating every hotel has a
computer connected to the internet
it's you know it's really
sneaking into the refrigerator at
midnight to have the ice cream
right and like you know that's cheating
the best diet ever cheating in a way
that undermines everything you're trying
to do for yourself
right so on wednesday it's like ah just
go check and see
and boom the whole everything you've
just done is is
in terms of your own mental adjustment
and mental health is gone
independent of whether or not amy
catches me cheating in which case then
i'm actually cheating on her
which is you know kind of like not the
contract that we had
do your words match your actions no
that's the foundational thing so there's
like getting through that
then there's the i only have this one
thing i have to do this week
right this one really important thing
that that just can't wait
the week in 20-something years of doing
this
i don't think there's actually ever been
one of those i mean
i've made them up right and i've i've
had plenty of them that have distracted
me
but i don't actually think there has
ever been really one of those if there
really was one you'd move your vacation
right you'd move the week to another
week and say look i really
you know we're on the road show for
taking this company public this week and
i have to be involved and i can't be off
the grid okay well let's move the week
so you know there were a lot of things
like that that took
making mistakes like it wasn't like okay
good cool let's just go do this thing
it's a commitment i made to amy and a
commitment she made to me
to build this into our life in a way
that would be
successful and healthy for both of us
do you have any particular
pattern to your scheduling do you try to
do it the first week of the quarter the
last week of the quarter is there
any pattern to that at all there isn't
some years we sit down my birthday is
december 1st
and i have been for a number of years i
used to do it privately now i do it
publicly
um i write a post that's version you
know it's called v
whatever my age is so i turned 54 last
december so i wrote you know
bfeldv554
and the year before i wrote b-feld v-53
and often times around that
we'll sit down and we'll look at the
next year and we'll
we'll try to get ahead of you know the
calendar nonsense and just block out
some weeks
um but they're not four weeks that are
necessarily just convenient for me
because
you know amy has a professional life
she's on uh the board of nature
conservancy she's on the board of
wellesley college where she went to
school
you know she's got some other
responsibilities um
you know that are part of the schedule
so some of it is just
navigating our collective schedule some
of it is also
when we need it so there are moments
where we'll have it you know and it's a
month from now
and we'll look at each other and say
we're you know we're fried we need a
break
and i would say even in sort of this
moment of
you know the covid crisis and the
dynamics of work
our entire schedule from march to
december we just deleted
we said we're not going anywhere in 2020
other people can but we're not we're
just going to stay home
and i don't know when i'm going to leave
my house again but it's certainly not
going to be in 2020
and therefore all of this stuff that's a
trip here
trip there or thing there thing there
none of that matters so let's look and
think what tempo we really need
so that we can maintain you know the
intensity of our normal life pace
we have learned by the way that saturday
to saturday is the trick we used to come
back on sundays
it didn't you know that didn't give us
enough gear downtime
and and we used to leave on sundays and
leaving on sundays just meant that the
weekend
you lost that front end weekend if you
left you know first thing on saturday
was when it starts
even if we don't go anywhere a lot of
times we just stay home
right so it doesn't have to be that way
yeah it's just enough space
it just gives you a more gradual
off-ramp on-ramp and on-ramp
or on-ramp and off-ramp excuse me the
next question i have for you
maybe related may not be related but
there's a there's a line
here that i have in my notes they can't
kill you and they can't eat you
can you provide some context for this
place it's one of my
favorite professional moments ever
maybe one of the most important ones
ever that line was said by
uh len fassler who is my
um one of the two guys that bought my
first company two guys
were named len fassler and jerry pock
were partners in a company that
was called a meridata which ultimately
was a public company kept up by uh
g capital len is my closest
mentor he's the person i've learned the
most about
business from over my career he's in his
late 80s
he he's just spectacular a spectacular
human
on many many many dimensions we had
co-founded a company
in 1996 so len and jerry bought my
company in 1993
ge bought their meridata in 1995
and len and i started uh with two other
people uh raj bhargava an entrepreneur
i've worked with
a number of times and steve mags who
also had a company bought by len
in 1996 and that company was
a company that bought web hosting
companies
and we did a consolidation of web
hosting companies
that really was one of three companies
that create a category called
application service provider
and asp was a precursor to
software as a service or sas and there
was like a rise up at the end of the 90s
and then a complete collapse in 2001
2002
and of course you know 20 years later uh
software is delivered
on the web online that was essentially
the business that we were
we had created we just didn't we in the
end we didn't execute it
correctly we bought a bunch of companies
i think about 25.
we went public in 1999. uh we had a peak
market cap
of uh right at three billion dollars
back when
a market cap of three billion dollars
was a big market cap for a tech company
company was called inter-reliant and
when the internet bubble burst we had
mastered
that we built about a 200 million dollar
your business so pretty sizable company
1500 employees
and lynn and i were co-chairmen so we
didn't run it we had an opera a ceo who
ran it but we were
he was full-time i was part-time because
i was also a partner at uh
at the time mobius we mastered the art
of
losing five million dollars a month
so we had built this company and
basically we'd grown incredibly fast
most through acquisition some organic
growth but we didn't have a
cost structure that worked and so as a
business we had
you know lots of real estate leases for
data centers we had lots of equipment
leases
we had lots of op acts and basically
five million dollars went out the door
every day
and for a while that was fine because
capital was freely available
and the only thing that the market cared
about was growth and so we were
handsomely rewarded for growing
incredibly fast
independent of the fact that we have
mastered the art of losing this money
now there's another company about the
same time
as us that had uh another company people
may have heard of called rackspace
and graham weston who's the ceo of that
company we knew of each other but we
didn't have relationship
and graham ended up we became friends
years later
and you know he said you know our
problem was that we've mastered five
million dollars of loss a month
he'd only mastered a million so when
everything reversed he was able to get
to cash flow break even we weren't
so we're now on the downside of the
utter collapse of this business that at
a moment in time had been the most
successful thing i'd ever been involved
in
and i was a co-founder so i had a huge
amount of
personal value you know tied up in the
stock that then was
every day vanishing um we were doing
layoffs we were selling pieces of the
business
we were just trying to survive this
complete
collapse and i was trying to survive it
in the midst of flying across the
country every week
having 20 other companies that i was
involved in that were all falling apart
at the same time right it's the same
time frame
and when i would go to new york i would
stay at len's house i had an apartment
in the city but a lot of the office
wasn't purchased so a lot of times i
would just stay in and purchase
because that was where it was just
easier and i have such a vivid memory of
waking up for breakfast
at his house because he didn't really
have breakfast so i'd wake up and i'd
like
take a bagel and i cut it in half and i
put in a toaster and i put cream cheese
on it i make cup of coffee and then
eventually he'd sort of wander in and we
go to the office
and this particular morning i was so
fried
and just so despondent and
i just knew it was going to be another
utterly shitty day
i don't remember exactly what was in
front of me that day but it whatever it
was it was going to suck
i'm sitting at his his kid's little
kitchen table
uh he's got this beautiful house in
harris and his little tiny kitchen table
in the corner
and i'm chewing on a bagel i didn't even
bother toasting it or putting cream
cheese on it this morning just
like gnawing on it like you know a
depraved dog or something
and uh he comes in and he sneaks up
he just comes in behind me puts his arms
around me you know like in that big hug
somebody gives you from behind
and you know len's short he's like five
five
it's like yoda like a jewish yoda with
you know ear hair and stuff
and and he just kind of hugs me from
behind
with this sort of heavy hug and
he then grabs me on the shoulders from
behind
and he says brad
they can't kill you and they can't eat
you
suit up and like
he he didn't need to be doing any of
this work right he could have said [ __ ]
it i don't want to do this anymore
why are we doing this like he was he was
in that thing till the end
uh he felt an obligation to do the work
even as it was all falling apart
even he needed money he was doing it
because i'd asked him to do it with me
that sort of thing
but that moment of i'm at the
absolute bottom of this but i've still
got [ __ ] to do
and him just sort of saying just suit up
let's go
uh was was a powerful moment for me and
and you know
i've had many many other up and down
experiences since then
um but ultimately you know they can't
kill you and they can't eat you and now
some people may argue that depending on
where you're from and where you live
and what you've had to deal with in your
life uh but in the context of
you know the us in business
entrepreneurship
trying to create things you know those
things are true they can't they're not
allowed to kill you and they're not
allowed to eat you
thank you for explaining the backstory
and
i there there are so many other bullets
that i don't want to take you through
at every turn of the world so far for
like the first 30 minutes being
bradfeld's version of misery
yeah no just like putting the cat in a
in a pillow case and wagging against a
tree that's usually not what i do in my
podcast but i
i it is leading somewhere i do promise
that
and i'll just i'll just provide maybe a
quick montage
that we don't have to go into the
details of necessarily to get to
a question so even uh now people might
be inclined to think well
brad you know he has this illustrious
bio he has all these successes
i guess when it's bad it's really bad
and when it's good it's really good but
there are also stories about for
instance some of your best investments
like fitbit
where even in the midst of this
meteoric rise you have these emergency
board calls and potential product
recalls and product recalls
all for the right ethical reasons where
you're puking into
a garbage bin after phone calls and
having these really
difficult experiences and visceral
reactions
i'm going to use that as a segway to a
blog post and this
is pretty recent blog post from 2020 but
this is quoting from that blog post
i'm officially dsm 5 300.3 obsessive
compulsive disorder if you know me you
know that i'm a counter arranger and
checker with some washing mostly hands
tossed in for good measure my magic
number is three
so there are few this is a multi-parter
i apologize it's a sloppy way of asking
questions but
you have spoken regularly since 2013
about your struggles with anxiety and
depression
two questions why is your magic number
three and
why did you begin in 2013 to talk about
these struggles well let me answer the
second one first
i discovered depression in my mid-20s
and i'm sure i had been depressed before
but i didn't have language for it
i was always anxious that anxiousness
translated itself in a
often in a very positive way right it
created focus it created intensity
it was linked to need for achievement
but there was always anxiety and the
anxiety manifests itself in lots of
different ways
in my 20s uh i had three things happen
uh simultaneously so i you know i'm one
of those kids growing up you know my dad
was a doctor my mom was an artist
uh we grew up in dallas texas you know
we had plenty of resources
it was an interesting place to be in the
70s and 80s
i think there were 2 000 kids in my high
school
15 i don't know 1500 kids in my high
school some big number
and um four of them were jewish so
you know i had funny holidays and i i
had some moments that were
not great moments you know as a as a
jewish teenager sort of surrounded by
people who weren't
um but generally i had a very easy
teenage years my parents were
very supportive loving challenging
in different ways in different times but
very much there for
my brother and i i went to college mit
is a place that is a
a daily assault on your self-esteem so
you show up you're you know you're at
the top of your class in high school and
you've done well and everything and you
think you're really good at stuff and
i remember you know a month in
everybody has to take physics as a
freshman and you know get a test a month
in
and i knew i didn't do well in the test
and you know i got my grade i got 20.
right this kid never made 20 out of 100
yeah i got 20.
right and i never get i mean maybe i got
a b in some english things somewhere
right like i thought i was really good
at physics i got
20. what do you do when you're 17 years
old at college away from home
and you get a 20 on your first physics
test i went in my room and i cried for
an hour like i closed the door and i
cried i know what to do
like how do you even process it turns
out class av on that test was
32. so i actually got like a
b minus c like who the [ __ ] gives the
first test so that the class ave is a 32
mit like that's what they do they just
they they make you
very aware that you are you know there's
a 10 of the people that are off the
charts but they make
the other 90 varia where yeah you're
smart kids but you're going to have to
work hard
so you know college i was successful i'd
started a company it was successful
uh i i married my high school sweetheart
not amy
i was in a phd program at mit at a very
young age
while running my company right
externally like everything looked
awesome and then three things happened
in fairly short order remember i'm
anxious all the time so i have
incredible amount of anxiety that i'm
carrying around with a bunch of things
the three things that happened in order
were one
my marriage uh blew up uh so public
failure
two i got kicked out of the phd program
because i was
a lousy phd student i was running my
company and i wasn't taking it seriously
and three is i was incredibly bored of
my business
so my business while it was succeeding
was not stimulating me in any way shape
or form
and these three things tipped me into a
very deep depression
when that happened i had incredible
shame
shame at all levels shame that i was
depressed
fortunately my phd advisor who to this
day is still
you know a wonderful substitute
paternalistic figure for me guy named
derek van hippel
connected me with his therapist who was
a classical
boston psychiatrist it turned out that
ocd
at this time was not well understood it
was just starting to be better
understood
fortunately i got diagnosed with that so
you know the
treatment that i had which was both cbt
and medication was highly effective
cognitive behavioral therapy certain
type of therapy where it's
uh you know you think about therapy with
like you know sitting in a couch
you know laying on a couch with your
back to the therapist is one type of
therapy this was the
sort of conversational therapy but it
was actionable around certain things
but i i really understood that i was
having a major depressive episode and
the thing that had triggered it was my
inability to manage
my ocd but on top of all of this is this
incredible shame
shame of all those dimensions i couldn't
tell anybody i was taking medication
oh my god like if anybody knew i was
taking medication how awful would that
be
so i go through that phase in my 30s
9 11 triggered another really intense
depression that lasted about three
months i was in new york uh i'd taken a
red eye to new york the night before the
towers fell so i
i woke up as the towers were falling
literally i was in midtown so i was
never really in harm's way but i was
terrified
and that depression was kind of in plain
sight right that was at the tail end of
the collapse of the internet bubble so
kind of everybody in my business world
was completely a mess
and now all the united states is a mess
for a couple of months because we're all
struggling with that we've been attacked
uh we've had friends die what does this
mean
i know these were not my only depressive
episodes but these were the ones that
were extended
profound lasted more than a couple of
weeks that i could really that i really
was in the midst of and in 2013
i had another one and this time
it was a result of a bunch of things
that happened in 2012
and they started with me running a 50
mile run
50-mile race in april of 2012 so i over
trained i trained a lot i was working a
lot
right my business world was going very
well between foundry group and tech
stars
i had you know very healthy relationship
with amy i had
lots of things but i was working really
hard and i did this 50-mile race i
trained a ton
i did the race and i didn't take any
time and recover i just kept going
and a bunch of things happened including
a near-fatal bike accident at the end of
the summer
we had one of our dogs died sounds like
a country music song sometimes
i ended up with a kidney stone that i
had been ignoring and just avoiding um
never mind that blood comes out when i
pee no big deal i'm sure that'll go i
just ate something wrong
and on and on and on and sort of in the
end of this at the end of 2012 i was
physiologically exhausted just
completely kaput
and i had this kidney stone surgery
which i had a very big kidney stone so
they had to actually do surgery to get
it out
i kind of took most of december off to
recover i thought i was fine i'm like
okay let's get back to it and i went to
ces
in las vegas computer electronics show
which is the second week of january and
literally within two weeks of getting in
to vegas getting to my hotel room i'm in
bed with a pillow over my head and i
know i'm totally screwed like i've got
i'm
in a depressive episode in 2012
uh several uh and then also in 2013
several entrepreneurs committed suicide
and there was a little bit of
conversation around
that but not a lot aaron schwartz was
probably the first of
of the stream and there was like a pop
of
oh my gosh this person will you know how
could this have happened
and then sort of it would drift away and
in this moment i wasn't ashamed anymore
i had been open about my struggles with
depression to my friends
i was blogging all the time about my
life or various
motivations a lot of it to be that i
think
by writing versus like thinking some
other way
brad kay pause you for one second please
don't lose your train of thought but
when you say i wasn't ashamed anymore
was that because you had been discussing
it with friends was it because the
half-life of shame just decayed
over time because that that's a really
that is not an interesting no it's a
good thing it's a good thing to
it's a good thing to interrupt with so
um in my
30s i was still pretty ashamed of being
depressed but i realized i was depressed
out in the open
by the time i got into my 40s and when
we started
foundry group we made a commitment tour
to each other
at the beginning that we would be
available to each other
uh emotionally available to each other
as partners
and our effectiveness of that how well
we've done it that has ebbed and flowed
over time
i wouldn't say that you know we are
perfect at that and it's been awesome
and it's never had
trouble but that was a thing that was an
important part of my own value system
from the beginning
is i had been in this partnership at
mobius where
some of the partners were emotionally
accessible to each other but many of
them were not and there was a lot of
[ __ ] there was a lot of
stuff that was not great through that so
we we started in 2007 with that framing
during that period of time all all four
of the original partners had plenty of
ups and downs
and we had lots of conversations about
it and so
i gradually became less uncomfortable
talking to
people in a professional context about
it my closest friends
that were outside of a work context
people like warren
other friends like my first business
partner a guy named dave joke
many people like that who supported me
through some of these depressive
episodes even if they weren't totally
tuned into what was going on with me
as we got older we had longer
conversations around them
and then one person in particular really
changed how i approached it which was
jerry colonna and i know you know jerry
and uh he did a
great podcast with you not too long ago
yeah the coach with the spidertech
jerry's jerry is one of my closest
friends i regularly
refer to him as my soul mate he and i
have known each other going back to the
mid 90s
i knew jerry when jerry first started
working with fred wilson when they
started their firm flat iron partners
i knew jerry much better than i knew
fred and fred and i got along and hung
out but i was really close to jerry and
we did some deals together and
it wasn't really until the late 90s
almost early 2000s when jerry was
kind of departing that fred and i
started to really engage with each other
at a deeper personal level and there was
some point along the way we're
we're you know where all three of us are
very close and fred said something to me
like you know when i was partners with
jerry i couldn't handle both of you
and when jerry finally disappeared for a
while i could handle
you and you know there's some it was he
said it in jest but it was there's some
element of it in terms of the emotional
engagement so
i'm sitting with jerry this is before
i'm depressed but
you know as as we're sort of going
through things maybe 2010 2011
and we're having these conversations
about how full of [ __ ]
most of us are all the time and you know
he's coaching now
and uh you know he's really pulling out
of
of people without having to do a lot of
magic
because his magic is right up front
um not the bad
the real and you know in this
conversation that we're having
you know we talked very quickly about
depression and he's been depressed and
i've been fortunate that i haven't had
the suicidal
attempt and really the suicidal ideation
activity that he's had but
you know the the depth of the depression
is something that we we talk about
pretty openly
and i remember exactly what the words
were in that moment again this is
2010-2011
but he said something to me that caused
me to change my mode
with the founders that i was working
with
uh and the and the leaders that i was
working with where i was already i think
pretty emotionally accessible to them
but i still think many of those
relationships are power relationships
right i'm the investor they're the ceo
so therefore the level of comfort that
they're going to have
being open about how they're actually
doing at any moment of time varies a lot
and jerry's point to me was
you brad can be a better leader by just
being you
and uh letting go of your constraints
around how you present you already don't
have many constraints around how you
present yourself like i always think
i've been a pretty
i am what i am and i try to talk about
it very openly
but he says you're holding back on this
dimension
right the fact that you don't ever say
you take medication you're holding back
the fact that you don't talk about
you know therapy you're holding back so
i carried that with me and when i had
this depression
in 2013 i immediately went back and
i hadn't been in therapy since i was in
my 20s i immediately went back into
therapy
and i remember the day that i had that
therapy session which was you know the
first therapy session with a new
therapist is
kind of worse than the first day of
school at a new school just kind of
sucked
and but i wrote a blog the next day and
i'm like you know what i'm just going to
write about how i'm feeling
like i don't want this extra layer of
pressure on myself
interestingly there was a very strong
mostly positive feedback loop that came
out of that
some negative definitely people like why
are you saying this
the bad guys are going to get you people
that didn't understand why i'd say
something like this
why would you expose your weakness
plenty of
you know look when when uh i remember
when fred and i started blogging in the
2004 time frame lots of people said lots
of vcs lots of our peers said
they must have way too much time on
their head to write blogs right now
everybody writes blogs
um but it's kind of the same thing it's
like no you know i don't really care
what
anybody else says about it this is this
is going to make me feel better to
let myself let go of this shame
and i'm gonna let go of the shame in an
active way and if that's helpful to the
people i work with
and the people that i support that's a
good thing and
the other side of it the positive
feedback loop is
during this period three four months you
know i don't know the number
50 100 people whose names
listeners would recognize well-known
entrepreneurs well-known investors
um some a few well-known public figures
that i didn't know
uh reached out to me for one reason or
another i
i did a few interviews you know because
then all of a sudden think magazine
wants to write an article about
entrepreneurs and depression okay fine
jerry and i are in that article to get
like there's a little of that going on
but i had a bunch of emotionally
intimate conversations with
very successful people many of whom said
i was the first person they were having
a real conversation with their own
struggles with depression
with and that didn't make me feel
necessarily better but it made me
feel that what i was doing had value and
that created a positive feedback loop
which over time essentially obliterated
the shame
didn't just make it go away it
obliterated it it's like no we're human
this is part of the human condition we
can either deal with it or not deal with
it
and i'm fine dealing with it and then of
course
you know the if you look at the
evolution of jerry and if you read his
book reboot like
just understanding that if one wants to
have
put your adjective in like it doesn't
have to be better more satisfying more
successful i don't care what you fill in
the blank with
but make it a positive word knowing
yourself
and continuing to scrape away all the
cruft
and continue to recognize that we're all
flawed
and being willing to keep going deep on
ourselves
and to the extent that we can do that
without fear without shame
that is even more satisfying and i think
that was sort of it all clicking into
place for me which is all right i'm
gonna die someday
i hope that i have more good experiences
than bad experiences between now and
then i probably will
right because in the warren buffett
words i won the genetic lottery right
i'm a white male in america i happen to
be in my mid 50s i got plenty of
resources like
probably lots better than worse for me
and so i should be aware of that and try
to use that as a force for good in the
world
on whatever dimension i can
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
layered superfood founded by one of the
kings of big wave surfing laird hamilton
and volleyball champion gabby reese
layered superfood delivers high impact
fuel to help you get through your
busiest days i just had
a bunch of their products this morning
about an hour and a half
ago i love their turmeric superfood
creamer and the unsweetened
superfood creamer both can really
optimize your daily coffee or tea
rituals so i combined it with puare tea
a ten dollar bag will last you a long
time i basically
use the unsweetened superfood creamer
like powdered
mct oil so if i'm doing intermittent
fasting or any number of things i will
use that
and i use it at least i'd say four or
five times a week the creamers are
packed with real
plant-based ingredients like organic
extra virgin coconut oil coconut milk
and aquaman
they come in flavors like cacao and as i
mentioned turmeric
each serving is packed with a full range
of mcts medium chain triglycerides
to help keep you going from am to pm and
i have spent time with i've stayed at
the home of
laird and gabby and they are one of the
most powerful couples
i've ever met in my life they've been on
the podcast as well so they introduced
me to these products
and i've been hooked for a limited time
layered superfood is offering you guys
my listeners 20
off when you use code tim at checkout so
visit
layeredsuperfood.com tim to see my
favorite products and learn more
again that's laird l-a-i-r-d
superfood.com
forward slash tim and use code tim for
20 off of your order
lyridsuperfood.com tim promo code tim
you mentioned that jerry's magic
is up front by that do you mean
the questions that he asks or does that
have a different meaning um
a little of that some of it's the
questions i mean jerry has a well-known
superpower which is that people start
crying in front of him
in a group right away and people that
would never imagine that they'd start
crying
right and let their emotion out let
their emotion out and
one of the things that is so fascinating
is he's not really trying to do that
uh what he's doing is he's he's locking
in
on the person in the moment and being
fully present for the person he's
talking to he's then
instinctively locking in i'm using that
word on purpose on
what is going on with them and not so
much what
the surface level stuff is but
two or three layers down you know what's
really
at their core what they're really afraid
of what they're not saying
what they're not acknowledging to anyone
but especially to themselves
and he opens that door quickly doesn't
take
four years of therapy to open that door
he opens that door in the first 15
minutes
and all of a sudden the doors open you
don't have to dance around it for four
more years
and when the door opens i mean some
people run away
right it's terrifying but for most
people they've already committed that
they're going to do the work
they've already said i want to be here
and so when that door opens
all the barriers just sort of crumble
all at once
and um he is so good at that
one-on-one but but especially in a group
setting but doing it in a way where
everyone feels like they're part of the
experience rather than he's
singling you out it's not like you're in
a harvard law school waiting for the
professor to point at you next
you know to talk about the case and
explain what happened
or harvard business school or whatever
they do [ __ ] like that uh i didn't go to
harvard so i
i got to make stuff up about harvard but
it's everybody in the room is all of a
sudden
teleported to this place where
they're both empathetic to the person
who is engaging
intensely with jerry but it's reflecting
on them
it's allowing them to let their door
crack open a little
and then he stays with it and he stays
with it not in in a
hostile way not an aggressive way not in
an attacking way
just in this jerry way i don't have a
label for it
that at least for for my experiences
with him
take people to a place where they
realize wow
okay what is important to me very very
quickly
yeah he's very good at honing in and he
skips a lot of the foreplay which is
i find refreshing some of the
questions he's posed to me or had me
pose to myself
have really stuck with me one being how
are you complicit
in creating the conditions you say you
don't want
and then you're talking about things
being being said
you know what what is what is not being
said or what is being said that you are
not hearing or that is not being heard
you know these types of questions
are really i've found really really
fruitful
the one about how are you complicit in
the conditions that you've created
right is so powerful to reflect on it's
a conversation that amy and i have been
having
for 30 years right i work too much
i work a lot i work you know i
create time and space for myself i used
to travel
all the time i could complain about it
but how am i complicit in creating those
conditions like
i have completely i mean you do too
right you have the freedom to do what
you want to do
where freedom is uh a very american word
in some ways very
poignant word in this moment but as
again white men with resources we have a
lot of freedom relative to many
other people most other people on planet
earth
when i find myself in a modality that i
don't want to be in
working too much or not having time and
space for
my relationship or fearful of something
or whatever right in a relationship
with a company with a founder with work
with a friend that's not
healthy for me what is my responsibility
what is my role in creating those
conditions
and a lot of times when i look at that
and and carve out the time to look at
that
there's a tactical okay i'm not going to
do this anymore i don't want to do that
anymore
i'll stop doing this that's tactical
that's different than going
into it and saying all right i can
change that i can fix my schedule i can
delete some things
why am i doing this what is it
satisfying in me and is that thing
that's satisfying
a good thing or a bad thing and
is it a wanted thing or an unwanted
thing
and man even with things that seem so
obvious from the outside to you know my
best friends
i don't see them and i think that's true
for many people right
we're in complete denial of how we're
creating those conditions that create
our unhappiness create our happiness
that's good
but create our unhappiness create our
limitations create our
put whatever box around and put a
negative sign in front of it
and he again he is good at poking
through that not touching it and tapping
it and
but just barreling into it and saying
all right here we are in this box let's
talk about all the mess that's in this
box
there's something also very special
about i haven't interacted with jerry in
a group environment
but in small group environments
particularly
and this this is what often happens when
people self select
to interact with someone like jerry is
someone will break the ice and really
express vulnerability which
gives you permission and
sort of greases the skids for you to do
the same so in some respects you might
anticipate that
that being forthcoming and vulnerable in
a group environment would be harder but
i think for a lot of people it's
actually easier
so i do think there is something it's a
good insight i mean it's probably one of
the reasons why group therapy is a thing
um he uh he and reboot his company
reboot
have done uh they started off doing ceo
retreats and then he and i
i hosted a number of vc retreats i don't
know how many we've done now five or six
and we do them i have a a separate
building
on our we have 40 acres just on the edge
of boulder and i have a separate
building i call the carriage house
and it's two stories and the upstairs is
perfect retreat space and the downstairs
is like a place you could have
uh you know non-profit fundraisers or
dinners
or whatever and um he
and and the reboot team would would take
over the space for four days
and my only request of the people that
came is that they don't come to the
house they don't bother
you know i have a sort of like here's
the area around my house specifically
but you can wander the land you can
wander the property you can go sit by
the swimming pool you can do whatever we
have a fire pit they do a fire ceremony
at the end of the thing
and i would typically go for a day
um the first one i went for the first
three days and it's a four day long
thing
and my observation having now been to
three or four days of a couple of ceo
ones
and a couple of the vc ones and then
having gone for
between a meal and a day to the rest of
the vc ones
everybody shows up with their armor on
and you know imagine a bunch of vcs
showing up to a four day thing like this
and
and they've got their armor on or or
ceos either one
and you know the beginning of it is a
little group bonding
and a little bit like recognizing that
you've got your armor on
but because it's so fast you very
quickly realize that your
armor is just making you uncomfortable
and sweaty and it's weighing you down
and it's hard to sit so you start taking
your armor off
and then somebody just takes their armor
off
and goes for it and after that first
person does it
the next thing that happens is everybody
stands up takes their armor off
throws it out the window and then you're
off to the races and i've seen this
happen
every single time and it usually happens
within the first couple hours and it's
it's remarkable
and now i think of you as having a very
kind of rule-based
uh engineering mind how do you choose
you can answer either of these how did
you choose your therapist when you got
back on the horse and decided
to get back in that game or what do you
say to someone
let's just call let's just assume it's a
technical founder right someone who has
kind of an engineering mind
and they ask you for advice as to how
they should choose a therapist
because there is every possible flavor
of therapist on the spectrum every
possible style what are your thoughts
for yourself
and when you went back to choose a
therapist or for someone asking you how
they should choose or find a therapist
you reminded me that i never answered
why three is my magic number
um we'll come back to that
so i've i've chosen two therapists i
chose a therapist in my
20s and i chose a therapist in my late
40s
and here's how i chose a therapist each
time
a person who i had immense
respect admiration
uh love for
recommended their therapist or a
therapist
they knew well that they thought
would be good for me and they did it
with no strings attached so in the first
case
in my 20s it was eric von hippo's
therapist my my phd advisor's therapist
and i probably didn't
i was in such a bad spot that i probably
couldn't have done an evaluative process
i just needed some help
and i had had one prior bad therapy
experience which was
before my first wife and i split up um
we went to she was going to a therapist
uh or she had started going to a
therapist and then uh
her therapist or she suggested that i
come and we do couples therapy together
which i have subsequently learned is a
terrible idea
if one of the partners has already been
seeing a therapist
and we had one session and i don't know
where malpractice is loaded right i felt
attacked for the entire 50 minutes by
her therapist
and that that was it like if we didn't
go back and like our
our relationship was probably already
done before i went to the therapy
session
uh or certainly was done before i went
to the therapy session just then got to
that point so i already had a bad
experience
with eric's therapist the other thing is
his name was dr mogul
and i thought for an entrepreneur that
was the perfect name for a therapist
and but i wasn't i was in shape where i
didn't i was in a place where i didn't
have evaluative criteria i couldn't have
done anything but he was he was well
suited for me he was what i needed in
the moment so i got lucky in some ways
but it was because eric knew me well
enough
and i trusted eric and so that worked
the second time
my therapist was recommended to me by
jerry and it was
a friend of jerry's not a therapist of
jerry's and i
i said to jerry i want to do therapy
again
i'm not really sure what i want this
time around but i want a longer term
relationship the first time i've done it
for four years i said i
i don't know whether this is a a
four-year thing or a 20-year thing but i
want somebody who could have a 20-year
relationship with
because i'm in a place in my life i
think i was 47
i know i'm in mid-life i know stuff is
shifting
i know my hormones are shifting i know
what
matters to me is changing i know i can't
run a seven minute mile anymore
even if i'd like to i want somebody that
i can sort of navigate through this next
phase with and i said
and i don't want a psychiatrist
i really want you know it's bolder i
want somebody who has
you know classical training but i want
them to be you know earthy crunchy
hippie buddha-y whatever i said
i want that in my life at this stage and
he said i got the perfect person for you
and it
it was a you know classically trained
psychologist named mcandrew
his last name is his first name and his
first name his last name which which
got me a hello and uh
he there's a school in boulder called
naropa that was one of the very first
alternative schools in the country may
have been the first one
that was buddhist yeah and very famous
from the 1970s a key part of boulder
uh and mcandrew teaches at boulder so he
was a naropa professor
jerry may still be has for a long time
been chair of naropa
and you know you kind of go on his
website and he's a
uh for high achievers for entrepreneurs
for people that are
you know athletes serious again serious
high achievers
and you read it and it's like the mix of
high achiever and buddhist
and it kind of jumped off the page of me
and my response was yeah okay what the
[ __ ] i'll try this
and it's been great by the way when i
say it's been great like i've had plenty
of really crappy sessions i've had
plenty of moments where i didn't want to
go
you know i've gone through phases where
i passively avoided things i'm too busy
i need to cancel this one i'll see you
in two weeks like
lots of my own [ __ ] getting in the way
and and mckenzie is very very patient
through all that
back to your question i have recommended
many many people now to him
not to him as a therapist but to him as
a referrer
so one of the things that i find as a
really useful thing
is then comes from my experience here if
you are thinking about getting therapy
and you don't know where to go and
you're scared or you're
sort of stuck or you're you know you
just don't know where to start
finding a friend or a colleague
that has done therapy asking them
if you could talk to their therapist to
have their therapist
refer you to one of their colleagues
most therapists
will do that for we'll do an hour
session or a 50-minute session
with the idea that they're not your
therapist but they're trying to make a
few referrals for you
the other place if you have a good
doctor
that's you know general practitioner who
you you feel comfortable with
most general practitioners will have a
network of a couple of therapists
and one of the mistakes i think people
make is they feel like whoever they get
referred to first is the person that
they should
work with and their homework assignment
and that's the key it's not that it's
what you're really doing is you're
shopping
and you're asking even the people you're
talking to
who they think you should talk to now if
you're in incredible distress you might
just land with
a person but if you're in a place where
like i really want to make progress here
um asking the referral to the referral
is a useful technique last comment i'd
make on this
therapist and coach are totally
different things
and it's really important to recognize
that especially for the entrepreneurs or
you know business people listening to
this coaches are really valuable totally
different thing than the therapist
and there's a lot of value actually in
having
both a coach and a therapist especially
if you're leading something and you're
looking for
how to get better at leading something
while understanding yourself better
what is the role of therapist versus
coach for you
is the therapist the salve and the coach
the whip at work
like looking for monopoly pieces right
um
uh the here's how i describe therapy and
here's how i describe coaching
for therapy i pay somebody
or my you know if you have insurance
your insurance pays somebody
you pay them to sit and listen to you
for 50 minutes you're going to in my
case i go to planet brad
and if i want to talk for 50 minutes
uninterrupted he has to listen to me
and you know it gets pretty boring
talking for 50 minutes and having
somebody look at you all the time
sometimes it's not but it
you know if you do it week after week
after week eventually things start to
shift
and the therapist is guiding you to go
deeper
to explore and understand what's
actually going on
and what's at the root cause of what's
going on
and how your lived history is impacting
your current behavior
and on and on and on right so it's
really very much
you showing up and the therapist over a
long period of time
helping you deconstruct yourself across
all dimensions
but with you as the central focus a
coach
and and that would deconstruct is
important because it's
deconstruct and presumably reconstruct
in ways you want
if anybody's ever done any kind of
athletics
it can be junior high school athletics
you had a coach
and that coach helped you train and that
coach helped keep track of what was
going on
and that coach gave you exercises
and that coach had an emotional
relationship with you
as he or she tried to help you become
better
at whatever your craft was
and really the coach is focused on you
and your craft
whereas the therapist is focused on
deconstructing you and your lived
experience
there are many other pieces of that but
that's generally how i think about it
stopping the whip is kind of okay i mean
the coach is the whip right the coach is
the one saying come on
but a really good coach is also you know
there's there's there's part therapy i
mean jerry talks about
you know to be a great and the reboot
way is a combination their methodology
as coaching firm
is a combination of two things one is
radical self-inquiry
and the other is practical skills
development
and i think this is what's unique about
reboot is you can't have one or the
other if you just have
radical self-inquiry that's therapy go
to therapy
right if you just have practical skills
development you're probably not going to
get that much better
you can read books you can go to
seminars you can do online courses or
you might get really great at doing the
wrong
really really great i like that really
great at doing the wrong thing it's the
intersection of those two
we're really great at doing something
that you [ __ ] hate
right you hate this but you're really
great at it so but i'm not doing any
radical self-increase so i'm not going
to acknowledge that i really hate it
so i'm just going to be miserable all
the time that's that's no way to live
you mentioned cbt earlier i just wanted
to give note to one
book for anyone who wants to explore cbt
certainly you can find a good summary on
wikipedia but there is a book called the
philosophy of cognitive behavioral
therapy cbt
subtitled stoic philosophy as rational
and cognitive psychotherapy by donald
robertson which i i found to be
quite interesting so for people who are
curious about cbt
as i am that is a that is a good
resource
i want to ask you and we're going to get
there about
boulder why colorado versus the bay area
for instance after boston
but i first want to ask you first just
to knock this out of the way
number three why number three so
here's how ocd works um
we all have obsessions and compulsions
just
normal way our brains work the problem
is when you have an inappropriate
linkage
between the obsessive thoughts and the
compulsive behavior
so you have an obsessive recurring
thought
and you then execute a compulsive
behavior
that has no correlation to it but it's
your effort
you know as a person with ocd to try to
control your environment
examples would be and this is why one of
the the
things that people with ocd have is
they're known as checkers or counters
right they count
things they're constantly checking
things they're arranging and ordering
things and people will say i have ocd
when they're like orderly and clean
orderly and clean is not
ocd it's only if if the thing isn't
orderly and clean my mother will die
right if i don't eat this
carrot in three bites i will lose a
client
if i don't straighten all the cigarettes
so that they're parallel to the street
as i walk from my apartment to my office
in boston
while touching all the signs with my
right hand
my wife will have an affair
that's ocd on top of it
um you know it just that last example
the absurdity of it is
most people with ocd are very
germophobic and and very don't like dirt
right wash your hands a lot
and so the whole idea of trying to
straighten all the cigarettes on the
street
and touch all the dirty sides on the way
to the office is just
stupid but but that's what it is and you
have this immense cognitive
load in your head that's around this
anxiety
um and it's really all just this effort
to control your
ones environment the trick to ocd is
breaking the link
so we still have obsessions we still
have compulsions
my favorite number is three i don't know
why
however it became my number and so i had
to do everything
three times uh when i
got home when i got to my apartment at
night i had to turn the lock three times
before i walked in the apartment i had
to
close jiggle the door handle three times
when i closed it i had to turn the lock
three times i closed it
when i took a shower i had to turn the
shower on off on off on
off before i could get in and then i
have to turn it on off on off on
off after i got out uh and then after i
got out because three is my magic number
i'd have to turn it on off on
off on off again and if i and
on and on and on if i didn't do
something three times here's where my
engineer brain kicks in i had to do it
nine times
right i love three like the combination
of ocd inflicted
superstition a new
all right so so what happens if i screw
it up when i don't do it nine times
got it dude 27 times three times three
times three
if you have ever had to do something
stupid
that is you know a stupid is the wrong
word if you ever have to do something
you're trapped
right you can't go do the next thing you
have to do it 27 times
you get it right because if you don't
get it right you're going to do it 81
times
and there's just some things in life you
don't want to do 81 times in a row
so uh that's how three became my number
and for some reason
um you know interestingly i care a lot
about symmetry so
in some ways four would have been a
better number than three
and obviously two would have been an
easier number uh but somehow it ended up
being three so i just carry it around
with me it's my magic number
so if we're talking about lengths and
breaking
these these artificial causal links
let's talk about another
what seems like a pattern interrupt and
that is
your life dinners can you describe what
these are yeah this was another thing
that came out of me and amy's
weekend in rhode island so she said to
me
as we're walking i want to have dinner
with you
once a month not a date night but let's
do dinner once a month let's do it on
the first night of every month
and just i just want a commitment for
that and you know hem and haoji you know
i don't know whether i'll be
in you know boulder or boston or new
york or
the bay area or whatever and she looked
at me and she said
do you have a calendar an online
calendar knowing full well i did of
course
and and and i said yeah i have an online
calendar
she says does it have the ability for
you to make a recurring calendar
appointment
i said yeah the online calendar lets me
do that
just how about if you make an online
recurring calendar appointment from
6 p.m colorado time to 10 p.m colorado
time
on the first day of a month and have it
repeat forever
i said okay i guess i can do that so we
did that and so
every month on the first day of the
month we have what we call life dinner
now 20 years of life dinners later so
what is that a thousand something life
dinners which is awesome by the way
we uh we have a little flexibility
there's there are definitely
nights where we we will uh have it on
the second or third because something's
going on
um but we we really commit to it we used
to go out
to dinner now a lot of times we just do
it at home taimakovic we for sure do at
home
we often not always but often start with
a gift exchange
and the gifts could be trivial little
things once she gave me a remote control
fart machine
um she's she's picked up a lot of
jewelry and art from
from it over the years and books one
dinner she gave me a range rover so
you know it it's a full spectrum of a
little
bit i really hope it was the same dinner
that you gave her
no no you didn't give her the machine
that would have been less popular i
think the range rover was to make up for
the fart machine but the farm machine
was years earlier
um and uh we sit down and if you're
a fan of software development and you
know what agile is
uh we essentially do uh the first half
is a retrospective of the previous month
and the second half is sprint planning
for the next month
so again very deliberately not a date
night
uh we have plenty of those this is let's
talk
each of us you go first or i go first
doesn't matter about the last month
and what happened and what was good and
what was bad and what we were unhappy
about and what we wish we'd done
differently and what we regret
and what we're really satisfied with and
anything just retrospective this is
powerfully interesting because we
started to learn that if
amy did something that really annoyed me
on the 21st of the month
in the moment i didn't have to react and
cause us to have
a three-hour personal meltdown on the
21st of the month
i could wait nine more days or ten more
days and it could be par eleven more
days it could be part of our
life dinner and it gave us
a marker for being able to resolve
the conflicts that we would have with
each other
or express things positive and negative
that we hadn't said in the moment
the forward sprint planning part of it
is
not go through the calendar for the next
month
but talk about goals aspirations
what we might want to do differently
what we're feeling in the moment that's
making us uncomfortable
about the future what we're
not you know afraid of what we're
worried about happening in the future
what's causing us in the moment real
anxiety about the future
and you know anybody out there has had
any therapy
or done meditation literally just naming
the thing oftentimes gets rid of a lot
of the anxiety
just labeling it just calling it out and
saying it out loud
um and so these dinners sometimes the
conversation
the life dinner part of the conversation
might go five or ten minutes and
sometimes it might go
three hours and sometimes there was a
laughter and sometimes there were tears
and sometimes there were both
and it's just such now
20 some odd years later a comfortable
way
to reground ourself as a couple
um roughly every 30 days in what is a
very very challenging and complicated
world
now you mentioned earlier that amy has a
temper and
in my relationship i i suppose i'm the
one with the temper
do you have any ground rules
for the details here are communication
style because
certainly in any relationship where one
person has a temper at least in my
experience
the delivery can matter a lot
uh do you guys have you guys learned
anything about
sort of communication style when you're
bringing forward
grievances or anything along those lines
yeah i
i think we we've learned a lot over the
years because we
we used to not be very effective when we
fought
because we didn't know how uh any couple
that says they never fight is totally
full of [ __ ] right
because we're humans and
we we learned i think there's probably
three things to pull out as i think
about him in real time the first is
no violence ever no physical violence
ever
in any scenario redline is the word
right
it's it's just an uncrossable line no
physical violence
now by that you you mean like physical
striking or you mean pounding the table
anything like that just a physical i
think
physical manifestation pounding the
table throwing something even if you
don't throw it at the other person
a sincere threat of violence um
those things are not okay it's pounding
the table
uh you know but but there's a big
difference i think between
pounding your fist on the table out of
frustration um
and doing it in a way that potent you
know jerking someone's chair
right i think pounding a fist on a table
sure probably would be okay in our
i don't know if that's game but but
certainly you know
jerking a chair or shoving the other
person or whatever completely
unacceptable not even sort of not
acceptable just completely unacceptable
second is
don't shut down while it's happening if
you're the one
that's being attacked by the angry
person it's extremely easy to shut down
and i find myself by the way
in many situations that i have outside
of my relationship with amy including
work situations
when i'm experiencing someone who has
what i think is extreme or inappropriate
anger in a moment
i find myself shutting down i i can't
i i don't know how to deal with it in
the moment
and we've made a commitment to each
other that you don't shut down in the
moment right i don't storm off and slam
the door
uh and lock myself in the room you sort
of have to
let it play its course what do you do
instead if i may ask
instead of shutting down do you have an
alternative right so for people who
might be
inclined to withdraw into themselves and
just kind of
blank out like wally shutting down if
they're
if they feel like they're being pummeled
how do you counter
what's what's the counter move it's a
couple one is i try to stay in the
moment with
the anger and again i think this is this
is a function of trust
right the more you trust the person the
more you can do this if you don't trust
the person it's impossible to do this
and there's a spectrum i completely
trust amy 100
so i know that she is angry at me and i
know that the anger will run its course
i also happen to know that when she's
angry at me she's usually scared
for something that's going on around me
or her
and so in a lot of ways it's better for
me to listen carefully to try to figure
out what it is that's causing her to be
scared
versus apologize for the thing that
she's angry about and
so in the moment rather than try to fix
the problem that she's
angry about i try to bring my full
attention to the situation
to understand and ask questions not in a
socratic and annoying a [ __ ] way
but you know in an engage in an engaged
in the moment way to try to understand
what's really going on
versus trying to defend myself i didn't
do that i didn't mean that that's not
what i said that's not what i meant
right
that kind of stuff which is pretty
natural reaction and really hard to hold
back on you know
especially when you're feeling falsely
accused which happens a lot when
somebody else is angry at you
they don't understand the whole
situation they don't really know what's
going on
and the third then so staying deeply
engaged
then leads to the third or the other
tactic by the way i use is i try to use
humor in those moments
we have lots of stories of us ending
this you know
where she gets out of an angry face i i
hate to make her sound like a terrible
person she's awesome
and she doesn't get angry very often so
it's not
uh it's it's not that i live huddled up
in the corner
of my house waiting for the next
outbreak um
uh it's quite the opposite but you know
in in those moments where all of a
sudden
you know i'm jumping up and down with
her in the air
laughing and making jokes about things
and spinning in circles
right or i'm doing something silly and
she can no longer keep being angry
because i'm just being silly in this
moment
but i've i'm being silly not as a
reaction i'm being silly because i've
kind of landed finely on what's got her
stirred up
and it's spurted out so it's kind of
like oh that's the thing okay
here let's see how many potato chips i
can stuff in my mouth now
uh and and that's going to cause you to
stop being angry or whatever something
cute
and then the the third and this is
critical
is that when it's over we both apologize
not it's not hers to apologize to me and
me to apologize to her but we both
apologize
and it's a real apology it's not a i'm
sorry you got angry at me kind of
apology
right which is not an apologist that's
all it's always a winner [ __ ]
it's just i'm sorry i'm so sorry you're
responding so poorly
it's it's just simple it's i'm sorry and
i'm sorry and
hug and and you go on right and
and uh i should also say like i get
angry too it takes a while it doesn't
happen very often
but i get angry too and she be she does
the same right she reflects it back
uh engages fully listens
of course i'm sometimes defensive of
course she's sometimes defensive
but you try to let that work its way out
without disengaging
and then at the end when it's calmed
down you apologize do you guys take any
and maybe in the early days it would be
a better question for reflecting back on
the early days since i'm thinking of
say me and my girlfriend i'm thinking of
couples who are listening to this
or partners for that matter who might
want to in some fashion
emulate this notes taking notes
helpful hurtful otherwise do any
thoughts on
taking taking notes if there's any sort
of looking forward
planning et cetera is it helpful to have
notes or do you guys
prefer to do it yeah for us it doesn't i
think it can be very helpful i think
it's very
very uh individualistic i am not a note
taker
i just not yeah i have a good memory but
i also
i have a memory that's a synthesizing
memory versus a
factual detail memory and so
taking notes actually clogs up my
ability to synthesize things
and so i'm also a very good reader
and i learn by reading so i've sort of
learned about myself that the
you know a lot of people say if you
write it down if you take notes it'll
cause you to remember it better
what i've found for many things not all
things but for many things it actually
interferes with my ability to synthesize
what's going on
um in the moment for amy
she is an extremely good she has she's a
i i did a memory extremely good memory
which works to
her advantage most of the time because
she'll remember the incident better than
i will
but also works to her disadvantage
because it's often not the details of
the incident that is the issue
and we've learned that remembering and
keeping
track actually gets in our way of
synthesizing and figuring out what's
going on i think that's a function of a
long relationship too
um and and just very very deep trust i
can imagine earlier in the relationship
uh or earlier in our relationship that
might have been helpful the other thing
which
comes from that is a lot of people
and we see this in business all the time
you see this in
hey you read a book you see it in
someone's book right it's not that they
make the point one time they have to
make the point three or four times and
sometimes you have to read the point
three or four times before you actually
understand the point
you know there is there is a reason that
uh
you know there's there's sentence
structure paragraph structure chapter
structure and business books
that can be tedious and result in the
business book only needed to be about 20
pages long
but for many of us we have to you know
we have to cycle through a few times and
i think that's especially true in
conflict
because when you're confronted with
conflict the first thing that you
see or respond to often is not the
source of the conflict
it is often not either the the root
cause the thing
that's even triggered it and the the
person who's angry may be articulating
their anger in a way they think
resembles what's what's going on but
you're probably not hearing
what they're saying properly in that
first moment
because you're trying to get oriented
and dealing with your own fight or
flight
reaction especially if it's someone that
you have a
you know intimate trusted relationship
with if it's just some random person
different and that's sort of secure
answer for me
uh writing stuff down is not helpful but
i could see how for some couples
it is i think the practice also by the
way of of the retrospective
right okay you had to fight you know
don't go off into your corners and each
sit down with your journal and write
what just happened
uh but agree agree to sit back down
especially early in a relationship agree
to sit back down in a couple of days
three days from now you know let's have
lunch and let's talk about this and
between now and then let's each
in our own way think about like what was
really going on
and have those conversations and i know
that amy and i have had many of those
types of conversations
over the last 20 years on our live
dinners on our week off the grid like
you know that that is part of the
content it's
we're no longer talking about is our
relationship going to work and why our
relationship isn't working
we're talking about the next level of it
where
you know we're actually exploring what's
going on with each of us as individuals
in these moments where things
don't feel good or when things by the
way the other end of the spectrum feel
really good
there's all sorts of stuff that i want
to cover and i think we're going to
probably run out of time i
am going to come to the colorado versus
other options but just
very quickly the digital sabbath
going without email without phone from
friday night to sunday morning how often
do you guys what's
what's your hit rate on on doing that uh
eighty percent of time what if that's
five three out of four four to five
um yeah the uh it started i i didn't
used to do it i used to work
my work rhythm was that i would use half
a day on saturday
to catch up uh usually in the morning
and then i do a long run uh on sunday
mornings
usually and then i'd work i probably
work
another half day a full day on sundays
and
even you know even into 2013 i
you know the number of hours per week
it's again i stopped thankfully i
stopped having to keep track of the
problems the week i worked
uh in about 2002 amy didn't make me keep
doing that for the last 20 years
but i would go through you know phases
where the total number of hours a week i
worked
probably diminished if you didn't count
things like
travel and you didn't count things like
all of those
you know hour or two hour in front of
your computer just catching up on stuff
right which is easy to dismiss that
you're actually spending time working
versus
like you know living or rejuvenating
yourself or taking care of yourself um
so uh when i when i had this depressive
episode in 2013
i had done plenty of again weeks off the
grid amy said why don't you
take a day a week off like just don't
work a day a week and by the way
when i was depressed i was having
trouble like getting out of bed so it
wasn't
like that was a that was a hard thing to
agree to i was like yeah that sounds
great
and you know i'm i'm not religious but
i'm i'm i'm culturally jewish of the
jewish tradition i'm like you know what
i know plenty of very successful
religious
friends religious jewish friends who
take the sabbath off completely
you know friday night to saturday night
and so
i just said i'm going to apply the week
off the grid to friday night
to and i do it to sunday morning because
i found that if i
got back on the grid saturday night that
was kind of silly for my friend a
reference kind of defeats the purpose
and we kind of use sundown as the
trigger um although
it's not a hard boundary and you know
colorado in the summer sun doesn't go
down until 8 30 right now so and i
we we have a place in alaska sometimes
uh when we're in alaska
you know the sun doesn't go down till
two in the morning like it's not quite
the right trigger
but it's it's kind of the point where
i'm like you know what i've had enough
i'm done and i'll
i'll pick this back up on sunday and
what i've found over i've been now doing
this for many years
when i go out of phase with it for any
period of time
and i had a period at the beginning of
the covid crisis where i was spending a
lot of my time working on stuff
on the private sector side but for the
state of colorado you know as we're
dealing with a bunch of stuff on both
the health side
and the economic side and dealing with
some stuff on the mental health side
just trying to rally a bunch of people
in the private sector to help the state
and specifically we have a fantastic
governor in colorado jared polis who's a
very successful entrepreneur and a good
friend
and sort of in that period i think i i
skipped three weeks
right so i worked all day saturday all
day sunday
and by the end of the third week of that
i was broken
like i could feel i could feel i was
done like i wasn't going to make it
another week unless i took a break
and so in a lot of ways in in
it's helped me sustain a pretty heavy
work intensity
over a long period of time by really
completely disconnecting
for that 24 hour period for for some
period of time
actually for a long period of time i was
doing screen free saturdays
to the best of my ability and i would
use google maps for certain things but
outside of that really texting to
coordinate meeting up with friends and
google maps outside of that it was
browser free laptop free and
you really do notice the
gear shift or i should say the gears
grinding when that gets removed for any
extended period
here's here's the flip side of it i that
i think is so
amazingly wonderful in some ways i like
to take naps in the afternoon so
i pretty much take a nap every saturday
afternoon and
i remember this is a long time ago i
remember
a saturday afternoon and i i'm a big
reader and i
i just didn't feel like reading and i
had gone for a run and i've taken a
and i was kind of bored
which almost never happens to me because
i fill up my world with
stuff all the time right i don't allow
myself the luxury of being bored because
i always have too much to do
which is a whole nother version of
it's it's basically boredom aversion
right like i don't want to be bored so
therefore i will find more stuff to do
because i'm afraid of not having
anything to do
that's in and of itself got some uh
plenty of grist for the therapist mill
and i said to amy i kind of feel a
little bored
and she laughed and she said isn't it
wonderful
and it is really helpful to sometimes
just sort of
look out the window or you know sit in
your backyard
and feel like i actually don't have
anything i have to be doing right now
other than be right here
and for many people in today's world
it's hard to do and so i've let that be
part of it which is
okay i've got my day off on saturday
here are the three books i'm going to
read and i'm going to go for a run i'm
going to make sure i get all these
things done and i'm going to
that's not what it's for it's for just
you know
take a deep breath reflect and let the
day unfold you mentioned reading
i'm going to i'm gonna all roads lead to
colorado and this question i keep
promising but you mentioned reading i
have a list here
of some of your favorite books and i'm
just gonna go through them real quick
and then
ask a quick question on this
zen in the art of motorcycle maintenance
by piercing battlestar galactica ronald
d
moore snow crash by neil stevenson
neuromancer william gibson and if i'm
getting this title correctly
the startup community community is that
right by mighty networks
uh if we're looking at the first
four which are all fiction
and you are recommending one of them to
someone who has been a non-fiction
purist for a long period of time
is there is there one that jumps to mind
as the starting point so let me let me
let me re-segment that a bit because
they're
they're not all black so battlestar
galactica i wasn't sure
tv show battle star glacier i wasn't
sure if it was based
but it's worth it's worth touching on
that and then the startup community
community
is an online community that i just
started a couple
maybe 10 days ago from the time we're
talking that's part of
the new book that i've got coming out at
the end of july called the startup
community way
i've been obsessed about the idea of
startup community since i wrote the
first book
around in 2012 when the phrase startup
communities didn't exist
and so a thing i've wanted to exist
since i wrote that book was a community
for anyone around the world that was
interested in startup communities which
is most entrepreneurs but then lots of
other people
and nobody had ever created it so i just
decided to create one and
i'm using a tool called mighty networks
that's really quite interesting
and well done and you know in a very
short order of
opening it up to people it's public so
anybody can join it
uh it's been amazing to see some of the
conversations
uh and and the level of engagement to
your question
of of those three books so piersick's
book
is zenon motorcycle maintenance is a
book i think anybody who makes
anything should read um i recommend it
to all entrepreneurs
i read it uh when i was in high school
and i've read it
every couple of years since probably
read it every three or four years i
listened to it on tape
book on tape once when i was training
for a marathon just to see if it sunk in
uh in a different way and it did and
while it's fiction it's sort of fiction
memory philosophy
it's fiction like memoirs fiction right
it's it's it's uh
fiction's the wrong word for it it's
memory philosophy
and the essence of the book is the
notion
of what the definition of quality means
but using a series of different
things that are happening to the
protagonist the narrator who is the
author
over his a period of time where he
descends into madness
against the backdrop of classical
philosophy so it just
it just combines a bunch of things in a
very powerful way
that you don't get the full value of it
the first time but it's
it's easy to move through so so i just i
think that's a book every human being
should read
the the two books i listed there um snow
crash
and neuromancer are important books
uh because they essentially are the
books that created
uh the presage the context we have today
um and stevenson you know stevenson and
william gibson are two of my
favorite and two of the best
contemporary science fiction writers
um neuromancer was first it was written
in 1984
and if you read it today you kind of go
ah whatever
but if you read it with if you time
travel back to 1984 and read it given
our world in 1984
it will blow your mind uh how he
predicted
and you know whether it's 2000 or 2010
or 2020
like just just the number of things that
he got
right as a predictive force in our not
too distant future
not just technology societal issues
humans
against interaction with artificial
intelligence
the dynamics of society how politics
work how drugs work
long long arc of things
[Music]
snow crash is written in 1992
so just just before the world wide web
begins
and i think the technology part of snow
crash
is brilliant but even more powerful is
the geopolitical part
of snow crash and the geopolitical part
of snow crash
is so incredible uh against the backdrop
of
2020 and nationalism and the idea for
example that states
if you had said to somebody a year ago
states in the united states of america
are going to start closing their borders
to
other states the person would say you're
[ __ ] out of your mind
that if you were from texas you are not
going to be able to travel
you're not going to be allowed into new
york
like huh and so i mean this book goes
way more granular than that in terms of
the boundaries but it's
it's awesome um by the way another book
in that vein that i think is
is as good or better
uh a book also the first book was
written in the early 1990s i believe
by a guy named dan simmons is a book
called hyperion it's actually four books
hyperion cantos
and it takes place over about a 300 year
period
and again all of these things that are
folded together
it's not just science fiction but it's
ai versus human it's religion uh it's
society it's gender uh
it's augmentation it's um
i geopolitical i'll overuse right but
the idea of
all of these things happening and the
first book is so wonderfully
fun because it's written in the style of
the canterbury tales
so it's a it's a pilgrimage where the
the first book that's the setup for the
whole series is
the seven protagonists in the first book
telling their stories
as they're going on a pilgrimage that of
course has a very
meaningful climactic end that motivates
you to read the second book the reason
battlestar galactica is on that list
is i don't watch tv that's broadcast tv
uh i didn't watch tv as a kid my parents
let daniel and my brother and i have one
hour a day
i like to give my hour to my brother i'd
rather read a book
however i like to watch tv that our
series and i like to watch
dramatic tv and there's a few shows that
are now classics
that i missed the first time around that
i watched in the last
10 years and battlestar galactic or bsg
is one of them
where it's a great space opera but it's
not about
being a space opera it's once again
about
humans and machines and the interaction
between humans and machines and the
dynamics
of the evolution of our species the
human species
and the machine species call it whatever
you want
and then everything that happens around
all the boundaries of humanity
and society as a result and the reason i
like these so much
and i'd put them so much at the top of
the list for uh
somebody who's not who's a non-fiction
reader or anybody that just wants to
dig in is that the best part of science
fiction is world building
and science fiction authors that get the
world building right
and really know how to do it
the books that they re they write are
just
truly truly incredible and it's not even
that you lose yourself in them but they
cause you to think
about your own world in a totally
different way
i'll give you two more contemporary
writers to play with that are in this
category
n.k jemisin who's a black woman who's
you know unusual in the world of science
fiction
because i think most people think of
science fiction as the domain of white
men um has emerged as one of the
absolute best world builders ever
and her ability to construct
these engaging incredibly complex
narratives that don't just get you lost
in the story
but cause you to really reflect on your
own existence
and what it means and what's meaningful
or not meaningful about certain elements
of it
off the charts another person who's
who's become a close friend i
i helped sponsor him when he was writing
his first couple of books
uh he's now i think on book eight or
nine or ten
uh that's that's really emerged now i
think as a a really great
writer i mean becoming a great writer of
any sort is a craft you got to do a
bunch of it as you know
and you write a bunch of [ __ ] you write
a bunch of [ __ ] and then eventually it
starts to be
better and less shitty and sometimes
it's really good
and then sometimes you write something
and it's not so good and then you try
again on the next thing you do
is a guy named elliot pepper and elliott
has become
in a category called near-term science
fiction writers that guys like
uh william hurtling and daniel
schwarzeren which are things that you
can almost imagine
are happening right now almost like just
around the corner
and so it's so accessible but then it's
so provocative
because of the thing that happens and
the way it causes you to think and
reflect back on how your current
existence is so there's some books for
you plenty to start with i want to
underscore a few that you mentioned snow
crash is a spectacular book
it's such a fun book to read also on top
of it
and uh for for world building i just
want to throw
another book in if people aren't
overwhelmed already
which is dune frank herbert in terms of
world building it's
a mind blower it's classic it's right
it's the beginning
the beginning of that genre yeah it's i
feel like you can learn
almost all the leadership lessons you
need from dune it is it is
just truly spectacular work i'm going to
toss one else on the
one other on the pile too for fun that's
contemporaneously relevant for anybody
that wants to
explore how badly things could go in the
time of covid
if this turns into the dystopic future
reality rather than the optimistic
you know everything goes away and we're
back to normal magical thinking
it's a book called the end of october
it's written by a guy named
lawrence wright and it came out
in april of this year april 2020
and so he had to be done with it in
february so before you know the
the the current pandemic probably had in
covet had probably very little to do
with the book
it is so good
and so terrifying and so
real on so many levels in terms of what
we've dealt with and how we're dealing
with it
and of course he goes and tells the
whole story right so it ends up in this
dystopic ending really really dystopic
ending
but you know the first 25 of the book is
about where we are right now
and for anyone who likes again i put
this in the category it's
it's it's not science fiction but it's
near term right it's
it was written about a global pandemic
that could happen in the future
oops it got published as that global
pandemic was starting
it's eerie isn't it kind of spooky
two last ones just because you've uh
you're definitely pressing all the right
sci-fi buttons here
two more authors uh who are
recommended to me that i've just fallen
in love with one is ted chang
c-h-i-a-n-g he has two collections the
book arrival which i think is fantastic
was based on one of his short stories
which for a a language obsessed person
like me is
is just how language structures thought
was brilliant
he has a new collection called
exhalation that i highly recommend to
people and then
ken liu l-i-u the paper menagerie which
was gifted to me by matt mullenweg
really
accomplished tech founder ceo of a
company called
automatic m-a-t-t-i-c you might see matt
mullenweg automatic in any case
both of those are short story
collections so you can dig
in and you
don't have to commit to a marriage of a
reading marathon
which you might feel if you pick up dune
i still recommend it but the paper
menagerie and exhalation are easy ways
to
kind of play in the shallow end with
with deep meaning without getting over
committed
colorado why why move to colorado
you're in the tech game you're a tech
investor you're a tech entrepreneur
it would seem that all roads in fact
should lead not to rome but silicon
valley if you want to be in the
epicenter of all the activity and deal
flow and
blah blah blah all that stuff why move
to colorado from boston
there's a couple reasons one is i think
actually the word epicenter is a good
one
i've never really wanted to be in the
epicenter of anything
it's not it's not my thing i'm more of a
loner than a joiner i am more of a
uh detached and uh or you know
disconnected from a
sort of in the middle of uh kind of
person so
i think epicenter is an interesting word
to sort of underscore in the context of
this
i grew up in dallas texas amy grew up in
uh fairbanks alaska we met in boston
uh we lived in boston for 12 years
boston was very good to both of us but i
like to describe living there for 12
years as living there for 11 years
and 364 days too many uh
it it was never home it never it never
ever felt like home to me
and you know when you're in your college
and you're in the early 20s like the
definition of home is tricky
right like what does that actually mean
you know what it what is home
uh when i was in college i actually
would say things like after i get done
with college i'm going back to dallas
which
my parents would love but i had zero
interest once i
got to like my third year of college of
moving back to dallas i'm like nope
that's not happening
we complained as a couple we complained
to our friends regularly about boston
and how you know we were gonna leave and
get out of boston someday and
i think our friends just thought we were
raw like yeah whatever we
we hear you but whatever you're not
seeming to take action against that and
when i sold my
first company i was 28 and i told amy
that by the time i was 30 we'd be out of
boston
and we traveled a lot together and we
like to explore different places and she
said her requirements were
ocean or mountains and growing up in
dallas i didn't have either
so i didn't totally get that but i'm
like okay well
not both either right and she's like
either i need one or the other
and you know growing up in alaska she
had both and
about two months before i turned 30 she
said to me i'm moving to boulder and you
can come with me if you'd like
that's a strong hand we're married right
and i had sold my company i was still
working i was doing lots of angel
investments around the country i was
still i was traveling a lot
west coast east coast boston new york
seattle
san francisco l.a occasionally somewhere
else
we had been to colorado a lot she'd
lived here when she was in third grade
and i uh had come here skiing
as a kid some and then as a young adult
some
and i and we always colorado was just
you know sort of the fantasy if it was a
cool place
you know the rugged the rugged west is
kind of a thing
in our culture um you know
independent of what you think about
atlas shrugged as a book or iron around
as a
philosopher like the whole idea of gold
sculpture being in colorado sort of
stays with you
you know and this this idea that it's
away from all the
other stuff right so not not the
epicenter that kind of appealed and we'd
been to boulder
uh we went to colorado for a two or
three week trip and we'd been in boulder
like on a december january day that was
like 50
degrees on the pearl street mall and
it's a beautiful winter day
that was not really wintry kind of like
remember this this is this is pretty
awesome
so she told me we were going i had a
staff job for the company that
i worked for so i could go anywhere this
was a meridata so
uh it was easy for me to just relocate
from boston because i didn't have
anybody working for me anymore
and we flew out we rented a house we
flew back we told all our friends we
were moving a boulder
we packed a truck and we drove to
boulder we knew one person a guy named
vern
and he moved away within a year
so we really moved out here not knowing
anybody
in 1995 and our view our goal was
nothing zero to do with work our goal
was to build a life here
let's evaluate whether this is the place
we want to build a life
and if it isn't we'll try something else
and if it is this is our place and
within six months
we knew unambiguously that boulder was
where we wanted to build our life
we bought a house behind a state park
in a place called el dorado canyon
behind el dorado springs state park we
initially bought a piece of land with 40
acres
and a house on it over time we ended up
buying
you know the pieces of land around us
and ended up having
a little bit over 100 acres there we
lived there for 17 years
and eventually as we got started to get
a little bit older
we've moved to the other side of boulder
right on the edge of longmont
uh we again have 40 acres and and the
land is an important point of the story
so
i'll i'll get to it in a sec uh and now
we're looking at the mountains rather
than being in the mountains
and we have this real sense of
expansiveness as we look at long's peak
each morning
and you know we have two big golden
retrievers and
they just kind of run wild on our 40
acres whenever they feel like it
although one is old and not running so
wild anymore today
i would be able to answer your question
when i was
30 i couldn't today my answer is
i don't like cities
i don't like being around a lot of
people i can do it
i can put up with it for a couple of
days we had an apartment in new york for
three years and i probably spent
a week a month in new york you know
between 97 and 99 not necessarily a
consecutive week but over the course of
a month
you know two days three days
that was okay same thing with san
francisco three days san francisco
then i just want to get out of there i
can't stand it um potent the peninsula i
spent
an enormous amount of time on the
peninsula during
my softbank and mobius time i lived most
of the time between 1999
and 2006 when i was coming out all the
time i lived at my partner
heidi rosen's uh in atherton
i mean it's a beautiful place it's not
my place it's not where i feel
at home and
i had formed with amy i think the two of
us formed it together
pretty deep belief that
it was important to pick the place you
wanted to live
and build your life around it rather
than
go to a place that you felt like you
should go to because there was an
opportunity there
and i've had this very long-standing
belief partly because i've been
you know started and invested in
countries all over the us
that you can create and build companies
anywhere that the ability to build
startup communities and really vibrant
entrepreneurial ecosystems
not just are important and are you able
to do them anywhere
it's actually an imperative that any
city with any critical mass 100 000
people
have a vibrant startup community and
one of the things that's been most
powerful to me about boulder
at least from the time period 1995 to
probably
2015 so 20-year period for me maybe
a little bit longer was i was in a place
that was
big enough to be interesting you know
100 000 people or more but small enough
that i could get my mind around it
and what was going on as i tried to
understand
the dynamics and the characteristics of
building a vibrant startup community
the last comment on why boulder and
there's positives and negatives
that i understand today having lived
here for 25 years
is both amy and i are very socially
liberal
and boulder is a very socially
liberal place so in some ways it was a
very comfortable
place to come there's plenty of other
socially liberal places in the country
and of course being in boston is very
polyglot so it's pretty easy to be
socially liberal there but growing up in
dallas you know not so much
right different dynamic and i was aware
of that i was aware of the overwhelm
that i felt when i was in los angeles
just you know los angeles isn't the city
it's
i know somebody told me once the number
but it's 80 something cities
you know and one in one thing called los
angeles like it's just overwhelming
um in the same way to me that manhattan
is just overwhelming and so
it felt like a place that could be very
comfortable
against that backdrop amy and i also
have a house in homer alaska which is a
town of 5
000 people that's where she grew up
until she was eight and we used to go to
homer for a month every year we
we still go to homer not as often maybe
every every couple of years
and it's again a totally different yet
another thing to live in a town of 5 000
people
you know that's 60 miles away from the
next town that has
10 000 people in it i like that so much
better
the negative uh which i'm very aware of
today is something that amy and i
started to label
a few years ago as an enclave
we just started to use that word and we
realized
that it's not a filter bubble it's not
that but it's an
enclave it's a very privileged place to
live
we built a house in aspen a couple years
ago
and there was something that we had a
house in keystone colorado for a long
time i love running in the mountains we
love being in the mountains
there's something about aspen that we
were drawn to because of the restaurants
and the
the town but also the ability to you
know be in the mountains and just be
disconnected from it all
and we pretty quickly we didn't realize
it until after we
you know had a place there and we're you
know living there on a part-time basis
that it was an enclave as well right and
a whole different level of enclave in
terms of
privilege and the dynamics around it and
while there are elements of that that
are appealing
there are many elements of it that are
very disorienting
confusing and not necessarily healthy
for the city and i understand those
things much clearer
today than i did even three or four
years ago
you know as i find myself living on the
edge of longmont
which is still a pretty comfortable
place to live but much more of a normal
town than boulder i find myself spending
more and more time
away from big cities because of you know
pre-cove and even lack of travel
and sort of reflecting on you know
what and where i like to be
and then most interestingly how our
technology today
has changed all that right you know
free covid if you had said to somebody
90 percent
of people who work in office buildings
or 95 of people who work in office
buildings
are going to be working from their
houses for the next three months you
know the person would have looked at you
and said never going to happen
impossible can't happen the
technological infrastructure doesn't
exist
well guess what all those people that
said it couldn't happen were wrong we
just lived that experiment and it worked
just fine
ah worked just fine you know incredibly
challenging for many people
super disruptive on many levels for some
companies
really negative for some companies
really positive but
from a structural sense you know could
one who likes to be
physically disconnected from others
still be
uh digitally connected to society in a
meaningful way i think we just proved
that the answer to that's yes
so that then changes again
the importance or relative importance of
place
in terms of how you build your life and
and
what you build your life around and
where that place is
i'll end this rant with there's a word
that i learned from john hickenlooper
who was our governor for a number of
years now running for senate
and is also an entrepreneur he was one
of the people that basically helped
create the microbrewery industry
and the idea of a microbrewery in the
first place i remember the first time i
heard this word from i think it was one
of his state of the state speeches
he used the word topophilia and
topophilia is
love of place and i think to be truly
satisfied i almost said happy but i
don't think that's the right word and
i'm not sure satisfied is the right word
either so i don't
i don't have the right word but
something that has that flavor
as a human you have to
end up living in a place you have
topophilia for
that you have a love of interestingly
if you can find a place that you have a
love of
that the constraints of living in that
place
are lowered because of the way that our
society works
in a positive way that gives you even
more flexibility
if you're able to find places
that are not as enclavey
and are more inclusive and that have
different dimensions of diversity
including being able to time travel
to other geographies while still
having that love of place for the people
that you're interacting with so it's not
the
physical love of place anymore that
becomes the dominant
it's a characteristic an important one
but not the dominant
that gets even more interesting and
i think we're at the beginning of that
shift in our society let's talk about i
think that
i would be remiss or it would be remiss
i'm missing my grammar
but if i want to ask you about
something that's come to mind for me
because uh
you and i have kind of chatted briefly
about it and that is complexity theory
and i'd like you to even just define
that but in the startup community way
well maybe it's not in the startup
community way but i'd just love to hear
how you think about applying complexity
theory defining it first
to life to what you do to problems
you've written a bunch of books and i
believe i i own and have enjoyed all of
your books
um thank you the thing that you know as
an author
is that a lot of times when you start
working on a new book you work on a new
book for a while
and then you realize it's total [ __ ] i
think that's every book i've tried right
it's not just partial [ __ ] it's total
[ __ ]
and that was the experience that my
co-author ian hathaway and i had
about a year into working on the startup
community way
we had uh started talking in 2017.
we met each other i liked ian we've done
a few things together around startup
communities talked about a few things
had a couple of long discussions
and he said to me have you ever thought
about writing a sequel
and i said i hadn't really thought about
it he said you know i think the world of
startup communities and all the people
i'm talking to like the book that
you know the 2012 book the startup
communities was really helpful and it
was foundational for a lot of
basic thoughts about building startup
communities but i know
you brad get the question and i know i
ian even though i'm not deep in this get
the question
of you know what now right i've been at
this for five years or you're in a
conversation with somebody in a city
where their startup community has gotten
to a certain level according to their
framing of it but they're really
struggling with what to do to get it to
the next level so we decided to write a
book
that was a sequel so we started writing
the sequel
and we wrote i don't know i made a book
like i started community weighs 50 000
60 000 words
probably wrote 25 000 words and we had
we were both unhappy
and it was hard and we weren't there was
no rhythm
there was no cadence to anything we were
doing and
ian called me he moved to boulder for a
while and then moved to london
and he called me or sent me a note and
he said i have come up with
a framework to use to describe what the
startup community weighs
i said okay he said what a startup
community really is
is a complex adaptive system that's all
i said
i said silence and i said 100 agree
so let me define that and we have
in the book and in general taken the
liberty of instead of calling it over
and over again a complex adaptive system
we're calling it a complex system a
complex adaptive system is a
particular type of complex system but
for purposes
of the startup community way and for how
people think about it i think the idea
of complex systems plenty it doesn't
have to be the
exact precise academic thing think of
three types of systems
simple complicated and complex
a simple system is making a cup of
coffee
right i listened to seth godin's podcast
with you recently
you know which was from a long time ago
but for some reason it popped up and i
wanted to listen to it i love seth and
i listened to madeleine aubrey's podcast
with you and that really inspired me and
i went back and i poked through and went
looking for some other podcasts of
people that i
i knew and i really i liked and
respected and cess was one of them
and he talks in the podcast you'll talk
about how he makes a cup of coffee in
his obsession with
a cup of coffee and may how you make a
cup of coffee
making a cup of coffee is a simple
system there's a recipe
there's a set of rules you can make a
really shitty cup of coffee
if you know you don't follow the recipe
quite right or if you're not good at
the pieces of the recipe but it's a
pretty straightforward thing yeah
there's different types of coffees and
there's different
modifications to the recipe but it's
it's a simple system you have a
input and a deterministic output might
not like the thing you taste when you
taste the output but it's a
deterministic output
a complicated system again has a
recipe or a playbook but it's got
a lot of different steps and the steps
can be done in different order
but you end up with a deterministic
outcome doing your monthly
quarterly or financial annual financial
statements
as a complicated system doing a
financial audit is a complicated system
it's replicable building an airplane is
a complicated system
it's really hard to figure out how to do
it the first time but once you've done
it
you just keep doing it
a complex system does not have a
deterministic outcome
you cannot predict the outcome from the
starting point
and the inputs along the way generate
outputs that become inputs
into the system there are lots of fun
examples
of complex systems but the one that i
think a lot of people immediately
get is raising a kid because even if you
don't have kids you were a kid
and if when you're
born the day you're born your parents
say
this kid is going to go to harvard
become a doctor
become a cardiology you know this is and
we're going to follow the
rules for how to do that chances are the
kid is going to be the opposite of that
um just because of natural you know
human being kid or they'll need a lot of
therapy one of the two
but there are many many things that are
complex systems and the idea that you
can apply a playbook or a rulebook
or a recipe or a sequence of steps to
get a deterministic outcome
doesn't occur interestingly when we
wrote this and we had this aha so we
spent
you know another year working on this
now i knew
we both knew a fair amount about complex
systems and complexity theory prior he
had
ian had been fascinated by this which is
why he landed on it i had been
fascinated by it going back to the 19
late 80s early 90s when i read a book
a book called complexity by and i'm
going to lose the author's name
i want to say marshall or malcolm
something but it was one of the the
early books that came out of the santa
fe institute research and
talked about brian arthur and the idea
of increasing returns you know which are
really just exponential curves
you know talked about flocking behavior
talking
m mitchell waldrop does that sound right
and mitchell waldrop
yeah complexity subtitle the emerging
science at the edge of order and chaos
okay so that that book i read like i
remember laying on my couch in my
apartment on bay state road reading that
book and just sort of it must have been
1990 or 1991
and and just you know having my mind
blown like it was just like yup yup yup
and
you know game of lie conway's game of
life and sort of
all the stuff that from that around
emergent behavior
contagion positive and negative feedback
loops words that we throw around and
many people by the way throw around as
though they know what any of it means
but then don't act in any way whatsoever
that reflects what those words mean
i was always fascinated with it if i
have a regret in terms of engagement
i regret that after i sold my first
company i didn't go figure out how to
get involved in the santa fe institute
because i think it would have been
super stimulating to me based on things
that i like we went really deep on
complex systems but in the end we came
up with a book
that uses the notion of complexity
and the idea of complex systems as the
fundamental core
for understanding how startup
communities grow
and evolve and differentiating very
clearly a startup community from an
entrepreneurial ecosystem because
they're very different things
and what does that mean and especially
what does that mean
over a long period of time because again
if the inputs are becoming the outputs
et cetera
i mean the thing that that today to this
moment is is
kind of baffling to me in a horrifying
and
wonderful way we are living in the
middle
of a crisis like none other i've
experienced in my life
that is the essence of a complex system
and the covet crisis is not a crisis
right it's a health crisis
it's an economic crisis that was
generated by the health crisis
it's a mental health crisis in the us
now we
we have a racial equity crisis by the
way
none of these crises are new and the
intersection of these things
is part of the essence of the complex
system each of them on their own
are complex systems you do not have a
deterministic outcome there
is not a playbook to follow there is not
a set of things
that we can do that if we do them in the
proper sequence all will be good
and we will finish and in fact the whole
idea of
finishing and in some ways the idea of
defining good
at any moment of time uh is temporal
because all the things we're doing
affect everything else we're doing and
back to this notion of
i love contagion in this context right
there is an idea of positive and
negative contagion
and covet is obviously extreme negative
contagion
but in business we talk all the time of
positive contagion the whole idea of a
viral loop
you know for anybody that runs any
business that's consumer-facing
is is positive contagion and if you
scale it up to society that's what we're
talking about in the startup community
way i mean literally that's what we're
talking about you can scale it up to
that level or you can scale it down
you know to how the startup community in
birmingham alabama
is growing and developing in positive
and negative ways yeah i can't wait to
check it out
i've watched these communities vibrant
communities pop up in
some of the last locations i would
expect
like for instance ottawa canada when
shopify which was
you know certainly one of my most
successful
investments although i was an advisor as
opposed to an investor
you've seen how one company with the
graduates slash alumni
and the factors that
made it such that
it could develop this this vibrant
ecosystem are really fascinating and i
mean you've made the point before that
and please correct me if i'm getting
this wrong but you have many people out
there who are trying to create the next
silicon valley by looking at the current
silicon valley but what
on some level they should be looking at
are the initial conditions
say 60 years ago that
provided the opportunity for all of
these
emergent properties to form what we now
think of as silicon valley right but you
can't architect it based on
the current view so i'm looking forward
to the startup community way
thanks that last statement was exactly
correct and super important right your
ottawa example and your shopify example
uh is an example of what what we refer
to as entrepreneurial recycling
and the idea is that over time it takes
a long time
right as you have success in a geography
in a city in a startup community all of
a sudden
entrepreneurs have a new resource which
is wealth and
if they care if they have topophilia if
they care about their city
um and it's not just the entrepreneurs
it's also many of the early employees
and
in fact many of the you know not so
early employees end up with
wealth and an understanding of how
economic wealth gets generated by
creating something where nothing
previously existed right before shopify
existed there wasn't a thing called
shopify
it was the product of a couple of
founders and then
a team and then more people and then
more people and more people and
eventually
you know today an incredibly valuable
company those people then
re-invest not just their wealth
but their expertise into new companies
in that community and that recycling
then
you know follows generations the first
generation of it's interesting
the second generation so when some of
those companies become successful
and those entrepreneurs and employees
and people that work for them and
leaders and
recycle their time their expertise
and their money it continues to expand
and if you go back to the initial
conditions of silicon valley that
happened
a lot over a long period of time and
i would argue that a line that ian and i
like to use is that even silicon valley
today couldn't recreate silicon valley
it would be by definition a different
thing and that's the essence of a
complex system you are creating a new
and different thing
and understanding the initial conditions
and
understanding the inputs and not
necessarily focusing on the people
or the activities themselves but the
connections between all those things
and how that then influenced where
things went is powerful and
i can't not say this because it's a
fundamental part of my
uh what i call the boulder thesis around
startup communities is that you have to
take a very long term view
like to say i used to say you have to
take a 20-year view from today
uh or you have to take a 20-year view
now i say you have to take a 20 view
from today literally you always have to
have a long-term view
from the moment in time you are at it
never can get shorter
and then you know one day you die you're
not part of it anymore but that's okay
because the next
generation of people are taking that
long term yeah
it's uh it's been cool to watch i mean
you've been
involved for so much longer than i have
but let's just say since 2007 in my case
what has happened with the distribution
of these tools
and cloud infrastructure where you have
say a shopify where someone could look
at ottawa as a liability
ends up being this enormous strength in
terms of talent retention because
they're not
in an environment like silicon valley
where everyone at facebook is getting
poached by people at google and apple
and fill in the blank
and that type of kind of talent poaching
and musical chairs of talent is so
prolific whereas
if you are the game in town
and you are the the promising rocket
ship in the form of say a shopify in
ottawa your ability to retain talent
is infinitely better than a lot of the
companies
who are dealing with a more cutthroat
dense
environment i mean you might even say
the same of say a duolingo
in pittsburgh although pittsburgh
certainly has carnegie mellon an
incredible
talent recruitment if you're looking at
a technical talent
so it's uh it's been really cool to see
i think
i think an important part of that tim is
that i don't know the shopify founders
well enough but my guess is they're not
playing a zero-sum game either
right if they're long-term enlightened
they're playing a positive sum game
where
what they're not trying to do is be the
only company in town
they're not trying to be the they've
seen it they've seated
i mean they're they're very active
investors in ottawa
like they're they're definitely a rising
tide raises all boats
and that's that's such a powerful moment
right think about that though in the
community right in the absence of that
if you have a city where
one company is trying to dominate that
won't be a successful startup community
if you have a city where the dominant
successful startup
is enabling and investing and helping
make that city better
and really stoking the innovation engine
of the city
that's awesome and so you know again
great example because you you totally
described the essence of it now
in 2007 i don't know anybody that talked
that way
and i remember when we started tech
stars in boulder people like boulder why
would i already go
do a thing in boulder right nice
mountains
and you know today uh if you look at at
boulder as a startup community you look
at denver as a startup community they're
connected but they're
two distinct things you know the amount
of that positive feedback loop that
entrepreneur recycling from companies
like
zeo and rally software
and datalogics and sendgrid
and now twilio after they bought
sendgrid and on and on and on i mean
it's you know the the characteristic of
the health
of the cities is that much stronger
because of the investment of the
entrepreneurs back into the innovation
cycle of their city
and it's really not that distinct from
you know
100 or whatever 150 years ago
as cities were starting to really be
developed and
the people in the cities who had
generated economic wealth
continued to invest in the institutions
in their cities
right the schools the museums symphony
the cultural institutions a lot of cases
the actual business institutions the
sports teams
right mark cuban owning the mavericks is
an investment
that he makes in dallas i mean it's a
satisfying investment for him but it's
he didn't make an investment in a sports
team not in the city he loved he did it
in the city he loves
yeah michael dell in austin certainly
also true
brad i feel like we could talk for 17
more hours and
maybe sometime we should but i think for
a round one we've covered a lot of
ground
and i'll certainly link for everyone
listening to
everything we've talked about in the
show notes at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast you can just search
feldfeld and it'll pop right up people
can find you at fieldthoughtsfeld.com
there's foundry group foundrygroup.com
for the social is is twitter the the
best
social location for you at bfeld yeah
twitter's fine people tweet at me i'll
i'll respond to them
you know totally fine my email is pretty
easily discoverable so just brad at
feld.com
um people have things they want to reach
out directly about i'm always happy to
get email
you you may get a few emails i'd
actually rather
i'd rather get emails in the random
tweet so i look forward to my
i look forward to the tim ferriss flood
of emails
[Laughter]
just put in the subject line tf so i
know who to be annoyed with
i'm just tim i'm just going to forward
them all to seth godin so so we're good
there so anybody
anybody that wants to get an email to
sethcode and just send it to me or jerry
cohen i'll send some to jerry randomly
maybe i'll toss fred in for good measure
fred you handled this for me subject
line forward tf
what the hell is going what tim ferriss
to blame it'll be
really besmirch my good name well brad
this is uh this has been a lot of fun
you know i want to ask one last question
which is one of my favorites
doesn't always sometimes a difficult one
to answer but if you could put a
message on a billboard metaphorically
speaking
to get something out to billions of
people let's just say it could be a word
could be a sentence could be an image
could be a question
anything a quote anything non-commercial
what might you put on that billboard uh
i would say uh can i have two billboards
one in the bay area and one everywhere
else
you are allowed to have a few billboards
uh i think my billboard for the world
would probably be
breathe um like that just breathe
uh another billboard which is not
probably the bay area billboard but
four places there's plenty of places uh
would be
some version of don't believe your own
[ __ ]
uh yeah maybe at the sequence breathe
or don't believe your own [ __ ] and
then 30 seconds later breathe
and then you know i i come back to they
can't they can't kill you and they can't
eat you
oh yeah that's a good one
which one for silicon valley would it be
the uh don't believe yourself
i'll let them choose they would probably
have a dot-com at the end of it so
uh yeah it's uh what a world
amazing beautiful world full of delight
and suffering and everything in between
and i appreciate you being a companion
on the path
and sharing your own struggles and
your own lessons learned brad so thank
you so much for taking the time
you're welcome and tim i appreciate you
a great deal for
both all the things you do but also
investing your energy and
bringing things like this out for other
people to the extent that
anything is useful anywhere i think you
have uh
you're a master of your craft and it's
wonderful to it's it's wonderful to
watch and it's an incredible honor to
participate thank you brad well i look
forward to our
future conversations hopefully more than
a few
and uh to everybody listening i will
have show notes as mentioned to
everything we've discussed
at team dot blog forward slash podcast
just search for
feldfeld and it'll pop right up with all
the goodies
including links to the new books startup
community way in the second edition of
startup
communities and until next time breathe
experiment well be safe and
thanks for tuning in hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little
tiny bite of goodness before you head
off for the weekend so if you want to
receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by thrive
market thrive market saves me a ton of
money and it's perfect for these crazy
times
thrive market is a membership-based site
on a mission to make healthy living
easy and affordable for everyone you can
regularly save 25 to 50 percent off of
normal retail prices with member-only
prices for
anything you can imagine really whether
it's keto paleo gluten-free vegan
whatever you can sort by that
you can find all types of food you can
find supplements you can find non-toxic
home products
clean wine dog food just about anything
and let me give you a personal example
of just how much you can save
so my last order i ordered primal
kitchen
mayonnaise which is made with avocado
oil it's delicious justin's almond
butter
and the first was 25 off the
justin's almond butter was 30 off rau's
homemade marinara sauce which is awesome
26 off all said and done at the end
of my shopping i saved 39
on my order so members and i'm a member
can earn wholesale prices every day and
save an average of 30
on each order i'll come back to that and
through thrive
gives their one-on-one membership
matching program every paid
thrive market membership is matched with
a free one for a low income family in
need
and you can try thrive market a few
different ways they have
the monthly membership which is 9.95 per
month they have the 12-month membership
for
five dollars a month which is built at
59.95
and right now this is exclusive to you
guys you can get up to a
20 shopping credit when you join today
now remember that i saved 39
on my order so basically with one or two
orders i pay for
the annual membership which is pretty
sweet so go to thrivemarket.com
forward slash tim to give thrive market
a try you can
like i said choose between the
membership models you'd like to test out
if it doesn't work for you you can
cancel for any reason within 30 days
for a full refund and on top of that
you will make back your membership and
savings as i have
or they give you credits to make up for
the difference so it's really
win-win-win all around and i would
suggest you check it out
go to thrivemarket.com forward slash tim
you can receive up to twenty dollars in
shopping credit that's thrivemarket.com
for up to twenty dollars in shopping
credit
plus all of the other great stuff that i
mentioned one more time
check it out thrive market dot com
forward slash tim
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they're worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my feet
it's helped with my plantar fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing that
you really have to feel
the theragun's signature power amplitude
and effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point
so i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's
thera t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n try theragon
risk-free for
30 days there's no substitute for the
gen 4 theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragun app and incredible
combination of quiet and power
so go to theragun.comtim right now and
get your gen4 theragun
today or you can watch the videos on the
site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it
a lot of runner friends of mine use them
on their i.t bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start
at just 199 i said i have two i have the
prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves the
soft attachments on that so check it out
go to theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
you